the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the 2022 st louis rapidom blitz is
underway in the capital of chess in
america top players from around the
world are ready to showcase their rapid
and blitz prowess in the beautiful show
me state most games started off slowly
with players gaining their footing but
not alaresa farouza who hit the ground
running winning his first two games the
french phenom is in sole lead after
drawing a crazy game against former u.s
champ sam shanklin
there is a three-way tie for second
place who will pull away and challenge
for the lead
day two of rapid chess coming up next
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day two of the
saint louis rapid and blitz held at the
st louis chess club we've had a
fantastic start to this event and we're
looking forward to more superb chess
let's go to the studio and start the
action with yasser and peter
live from saint louis home of the first
world chess championship we welcome you
to rabbit and blitz from the saint louis
chess club
hello i'm peter svidler and with me is
yasser saravan and uh how are we doing
today wonderful wonderful peter good to
see you as always hello everyone and
welcome to our live coverage of the 2022
st louis rapid and blitz tournament boy
the first day was fantastic and
especially that third round game between
purusha and sam shanklin i'm still not
fully recovered it was great let's take
a look at our current standings after
one round of the one i i want to and if
you missed that do take a look at that
but here are the standings after the
first day of play alireza there at the
top winning the first two including a
win with the black pieces against hikaru
in round two and then drawing that
absolute
roller coaster of the game against sam
three people one point behind including
mvl linear and jeffrey shong
two players jan and sam shankland are on
fifty percent with only draws so far and
then some very very notable players
below fifty percent including fabi
who started 40 but then won his last
round game and shakira who's having a
bit of a mayor so far yes indeed and our
format peter
the former is a templar around robin uh
first we play a rapid round robin we are
currently midway sort of in in the
middle of it uh with the time control of
25 plus 10 the blitz will be played with
the five plus two time control draw
offers are for button and uh the scoring
system is as you can see rapid games
count double with two points for a win
and one for a draw and then we go back
to the normal scoring
for the blitz and our schedule for this
term
uh the schedule is we've got four days
left of the event
we have three three days three games of
rapid today three games of rapid
tomorrow and then two days of
featuring nine
rounds of blitz on monday and tuesday a
complete round dropping per day with
colors reversed on tuesday and playoffs
on tuesday if necessary and as always
it's wonderful to have christian in
studio good afternoon uh christian
and uh you got something to tell us
about ali riza farouza
great to see you guys good to be back in
the studio for a day two action calling
the games of the best chess players we
have here at the saint louis rabbit and
blitz it was a fantastic day one filled
with thrills and spills that last game
between ali reza and shanklin was just
incredible and there are a couple of
stories that i'm definitely having my
eyes on first and foremost is the story
of one ali reza firuja who is just
simply having a great start to this
event after a subpar performance at the
candidates it seems like that just
simply rejuvenated him there is no more
pressure on him and right now he is able
to showcase his best chess in round
number one he beat mohammed yaro in
round number two he beat with the black
pieces actually completely outplayed
hikaru nakamura and that incredible
tense battle against sam shanklin in
which he was worse he was winning and
then he was also completely losing and
winning as well at the end but in the
end it finished in a draw what a
fantastic start for this young man well
on the other side of the coin we have a
player that unfortunately for him had a
very slow start that is exactly the
player that i'm talking about hikaru
nakamura a man with a legion of fans
behind him unfortunately for him he is
also the defending champion the 2021
champion here at the saint louis rabbit
blitz very slow start for him in round
number one with the black pieces it
didn't feel like he is himself he lost
quite easily actually against lanier
dominguez after that round two got
outplayed with the white pieces against
ali reza but a nice bounce back victory
in the final round of the day against
levon aronian definitely has him on a
much happier track going into the second
day and what a difference one year makes
let's see how he started in last year's
event well a much better start for
hikaru nakamura in 2021 two draws in the
first two games but then a very
important crucial victory in the third
round and that put him on the path
towards success needless to say he's
definitely going to be looking for
revenge in day two guys we have some
fantastic players and some fantastic
chess coming your way thank you
christian and that
minus two difference is a big difference
it is a big difference yeah i'm very
curious about that blue device uh fabi
has just shown us on screen yeah i'm
gonna ask him about
exactly what that is uh beautiful
beautiful venue there you see the
playing called the kind of a small
lounge area for for the players but
we're we're going to show you the
bearings for round four this is the
first uh round of the day today yep uh
and there are two games here i think
with which we really stand out which we
are going to probably be focusing on uh
jan is playing white against uh shahriar
the first game
that we thought was very interesting was
that game between uh hikaru and
mvl with hikaru absolutely needing to
improve today from his mediocre showing
yesterday and nbl had a good day
yesterday
they're also up doing so well in the
comments stories as well so we'll come
to that at some point uh sam shanklin is
white against iranian and then this
other game where
uh the youth the youth yeah
uh jeffrey shank who's having a very
very nice event so far playing white
against tereza ferrugia only
a point behind the leader there and with
the white pieces if he beats him he
leapfrogs him and
goes into the lead after four rounds and
then we have fabi against lanier to
round off the wily veterans if you will
the pairings for the day that's a very
very festive lakers shirt there i was
about to say uh it looks really nice nba
shirt there but i like the fact that
you're wandering wanting a person with a
t-shirt
you can't visually see that he's not
carrying anything
but also he's not showing allegiance to
any team right he's trying to right
just represent that like
yeah it's interesting because i wasn't
actually aware that he is one of the uh
i would say a surprising number of
people at the very very top of the uh
the chess
ladder who are devout
devout nba fans i think vaughan is a
celtics fan one of uh
the nba fans gustafson also i think i
mean magnus magnus magnus
yeah when you know lebron is famously
completely ruins his sleep schedule and
uh my good friend alexander grishok
always watches everything live in the
middle of the night and i mean there's
plenty
it's a very very serious pastime for
many many people and
there we see
uh nipomnishi there in his tan suit yeah
unacceptable nice game face
how acceptable
yes
and uh obviously uh they're gonna be
playing this week uh
hard peter and what are they playing for
yeah let's take a look at the uh at the
prize fund for this the price fund for
the rapid events in the grand chess tour
is 175 000 total
with 40 grand up top and ending with 7
000 dollars for the person finishing in
last
and the gct points which uh there is a
separate uh
prize pool for the winners of the tour
as you can see if you win the tournament
outright you get 13 gt points and if you
had to win play the tie break to win it
you get 12 right uh which is why there
is a double number there double number
there up top right going all the way to
one point yeah and just as you mentioned
in the grand chess tour as the player
gets underway
uh along with the bragging rights of
being the champion of the grand chess
tour there's a hundred thousand a dollar
bonus for the winner uh fifty thousand
for the runner up twenty five
for third place so sikaru
knows he's up against mvl uh mbl one of
the great knight or certainly but on the
other pause on move three i i think uh
well slide pause because obviously
higher has played a decent amount of
bishop b5 check but you also have to
mention that mbl recently has kind of
switched away from
uh from being from being a full-on night
of player he began playing uh you know
just as he
sort of not stopped but
started playing a lot less of the
grunfeld and a lot more of the qgas he
he began playing the petrovs and exactly
and the the other extremely solid things
against one e4 which uh was extremely
disheartening frankly for us for us
chess lovers why would you do that
exactly
depressing to see uh people shying away
from the king's indian grunfeld the
night or now this move f2 f3 uh peter
it's been known for many many decades
many decades yeah uh but when i
uh
was young the move e7 e5 kind of put
the variation out of uh i i think it's
uh
uh
i actually have looked at this recently
and the interesting thing is that e593
g5 wasn't really supposed to be any good
but i think right no no i think or black
yeah you were not supposed to just play
d65 here but i think the current
understanding is you can actually do
that and you're doing you're going to be
sort of fine uh there's been some
developments in that line excellent but
i think if people want to get a game
they play b6 here c4 a5 and do things of
that nature after e59 d3 bishop e6 white
obviously played c4 this is why the
knight stayed back on on b1 to be able
to establish this kind of a structure
and white
black generally goes a 5 a 4 here and
you get
very non-standard positions this line
famously was discussed during the new
york match between carlson and kraken in
one of the uh
tiebreak games right
on the final day but we did
we do see uh at least in our camera shot
we're not updating our games yet we did
see that uh
um mvl rather hesitated after f2 f3 i
don't know if he still probably didn't
expect it and e6 is a playable move in
response like he thinks definitely
exists it's just a a much more solid
line where you uh get
you know less of a double-edged position
uh and it's connected not with the idea
of playing you you can of course play
just a pure hedgehog after e64 but i
think the current standing like you just
go knight c6 b7
uh you castle and you go d65 very very
quickly
and you get positions which i think the
current understanding is those are fine
but
we do have e5 yeah e5 and hikaru did not
play c4 which is interesting so hikaru
basically what he did here is he bluffed
mvl off of a minute on his clock by
going knight b3 uh bishop e6 and then i
guess just going knight c3 exactly ic3
knight c6 bishop e3 and hp7 and we need
two which is quite an interesting
wrinkle yeah 22 does make sense because
you do want to have some play against
the 65 and having the rook on d1 sort of
x-raying the queen on d8 definitely
makes a a ton of sense so we have a kind
of a mix between like it's a it's a
neidorf structure but the paul is on a7
right and the knight got developed to c6
not to d7 right in these types of
structures in the nine of you very very
often in fact i think in the majority of
the cases you will see that knight on v8
getting developed to g7 but mvl
developed into c6 here also in order to
maybe rook c8 rook c3 um um after queen
e2 let's just put some moves on the
board castle
and we're going to shoot over to
christian here and say
is this topical uh
christian it's not as topical but it
doesn't surprise me because i'm actually
seeing quite a familiar name and that is
sam shanklin he has played it with the
white pieces and we know that sam worked
for hikaru during the candidates so
we're definitely starting to see
tendencies of hikaru maybe following one
of his seconds now quite an interesting
approach for black would be after castle
castle to go this move knight to a5 try
to take advantage of the queen being on
e to potentially having ideas of bishop
to c4 and now there's all sorts of
complications also without the queen on
d2 you very often don't have ideas of
knight to d5 and opening up a diagonal
so for example let's just put the queen
on d2 here castle cat castle and now
knight to a5 now i have ideas of taking
and then knight to d5 after the move
king to b1 because we don't want to see
queen takes d2 with a check so for
example if you go rook to c8 i can just
take take knight to d5 and now white has
a tremendous position because you don't
have time to take on d2 i take on e7 and
you're just simply losing a piece you
have to drop back with the queen so
we're seeing a lot of nuances developing
in this game definitely is going to be
one to follow guys
wonderful absolutely but uh plenty of
other very interesting positions in a
very non-standard position here in uh in
the game that yasser is switching to the
game between sam shankland and the one
iranian where
uh it's it's this kind of a new fang way
to treat the uh the nimzo with the
bishop d2
uh lines becoming more and more
prominent yeah and in my time we just
weren't allowed
to
entomb our bishop behind our pawn
structure peter we i mean we we put our
bishop on g5 and or f4 as a religion
it's still very surprising to me just
how serious these lines uh are despite
you know by this point we've all kind of
accepted right that this is
not a joke right but
you know when i first realized just uh
how seriously people are treating the
the ideas of uh you know playing bishop
just bishop d4 d2 on move four against
the nimzo or just as sam is doing today
1993 and bishop d2 and just playing this
way but he is uh showing a kind of a
quirky way to follow it up because
instead of yeah very unusual instead of
developing the bishop to g3 as you would
expect the bishop has gone to g2 and in
particular it's interesting because as
leon is you know clearly demonstrating
the king is still only one and you might
have to
uh show some
you know agility and
numbness here for from from white to
actually get it out of the center i'm
not sure what sam is doing he's playing
quickly so he would have to assume he he
knows what he's about here but yeah with
a lack of confusion yeah with allequity
i would want to get my king out of dodge
out of the center i'm assuming 92 is
almost forced why are we happy about
this like 96 94. it seems like knight c6
castles
or something like this and i guess i
just gotta get out of this uh very
awkward
rookie one night four we are slowly
slowly coming out of the corner here i
guess yeah right um
maybe it's it's it's it's a newfangled
way let's put it that way
uh again we kind of like
remarked at the start that shakriar is
doing a little disappearing act as i've
got
his game against nepo up on my board but
christian i wanted to go over to you and
ask you walk out your eye big
theoretical battle between the two
americans fabiano caruana and lanier
dominguez and they're actually playing
the petrov we know fabiano is a big
petrol player or at least he used to be
a big petrol player and lanier after
working with fabiano started employing
the petrov himself as well there's a big
theoretical battle going on in this one
this game has been seen this position
has been seen twice in what seems to be
correspondence games and the movie in
those games was queen to g4 the idea
being that after bishop to e4 rook to c1
black still without control of the
knight on e5 with the queen black has
the option of playing the move c5 now of
course you cannot take with the d pawn
because queen takes c5 is coming and
that's going to win a piece for black if
you do have to take with the rook on c5
then after queen to b6 it feels like
black is getting enough counter play
despite the fact that you have some
structural weaknesses in the position
the pawn on c7 upon a7 potentially in
the end game you do have a lot of
activity due to your bishops so fabiano
came with an interesting idea instead of
placing the queen on g4 a novelty queen
to g3 and by the way look at the time 24
minutes and 59 seconds for fabiano 22
minutes right now linear is trying to
figure out the nuances and the
differences of this move queen to g3 now
if you try to go bishop to e4 that's
already a mistake right now bishop to e4
was the move that we've seen in previous
games because after rook to c1 there's
no more c5 after c5 i'm just simply
going to be able to take with the rook
and after queen to b6 i have the move
knight to d7
very very intriguing ideas
if you do go queen takes b2 bishop to c3
the queen is protecting the bishop as
well i'm going to take on f8 this is
looking really really good for white so
queen to g3 an interesting novelty from
fabiano who was definitely expecting the
petrov from lanier and let's see how
lanier is going to respond to this
wrinkle
thank you for that christian and just
looking at the game between the youths
of jeffrey zhang and ali reza and i got
to tell you uh what's wrong with the
youth as of today when i
was a youth
we were
we were
swinging for the fences i want to put it
like that we may not know what we were
doing
but we were really going whole hog
trying to win and i'm looking at a
scotch
uh opening and um
yeah this is a four nights and uh i've
actually had a discussion on this topic
recently and uh
a discussion specifically relating to
this game because uh jeffrey appears to
be playing this almost exclusively when
he chooses to go one e4 yesterday
against for for instance
he went one g4 on one but if he chooses
to open with the king's pawn he uh he
plays the four knights
very very seriously and
uh despite its i think justified
somewhat drawish reputation right he
doesn't do it to make a draw he does he
does it to perhaps get a slight edge
and to you know nurse it for the rest of
the game and you know you win some you
you draw most of the rest uh there is
pretty much always zero risk involved
for white
and what reza is doing here
uh i wasn't very happy but a5 is a is a
clever move it's a very standard idea
here to try to undermine the the pawn
chain by pushing this pawn to all the
way to a4
and actually this knight on the four it
looks very beautiful but because the
rook on b4 is quite well established
right it's difficult for why because
white would of course like to create an
isolani on d5 by trading on d5 but the
the knight is always hanging on f4 and
you definitely don't want to be playing
g2 g3 g2 g3 doesn't really look right
right just a little bit of a wobble with
the h3 pawn already under contact so if
we assume that our plan at some point
should involve
c4 takes d5 we are currently a little
bit stuck
realizing that plan giving black time to
you know continue the counter play on
the queen side right i'm just thinking
i'm just putting some moves on the board
peter just bringing my rooks into the
city let's take on b3 and go the problem
is that the knight once again is hanging
so yeah i should thank you and we can
just think and this is the problem uh
even king thanks you know all right
and uh because of queen takes f4
uh the the weakness on b3 really does
require a kind of a
well
a semi move i don't know how to describe
it yeah bishop c2 is not very exciting
no
what i want to say is at some point i
have i'm playing for this yeah what i
wanted to say is because
jeffrey actually is has been doing this
very very seriously and alireza
uh you know modern generation of players
takes their preparation very seriously
uh he would of course know that this is
likely to happen if if jeffrey opens
with one e4 clear so i get the
impression that he reza
is not doing this randomly i think that
even though he's in 19 minutes
i still feel like you know he must have
looked at the the four nights in
preparation for today's round because uh
this is jeffrey's absolute main
repertoire right when i think about
players of the past they used to play
the four knights boris baskey comes to
mind and when i think about players
obviously with the scotch gary's name is
prominent but so is nepo i've seen nepal
play a lot of it uh have you ever
dabbled in it yourself yeah i played i
played
i actually played the four nights for a
while and i played a a bunch of scotch
at some point but i mean they're very
very different in spirit because the the
scotch often leads to uh
just a free-for-all like very often by
move 12 white has a look from h1 is on
a3 for some reason
and you know
the
these days with the with h2h4 move being
very prominent in a lot of positions
right in the scotch whereas the four
knights you will get a position like
this nice
which is much less exciting speaking of
less exciting let's turn over to
question today how do you have some
excitement for us
that's that's not a great segue
yesterday i'll give you that
but
yes i was looking at this game between
uh sam shanklin and aronian and i was
actually trying to understand what sam
missed because i think he missed
something in this position he decided to
go with the move a3 and after bishop to
f8 only then with the move g3 what i
think he wanted to do actually was to
play g3 first why i'm saying this is
because after the move a3 bishop to f8
and now g3 black has the extra option of
losing another tempo and waiting to
commit to the position of the bishop on
c8 with the move c5 and only after
bishop to g2 now i can play the move
bishop to a6 which is what happened in
the game if you don't start with the
move a3 first if you play the move g3
now the problem with c5 is that it
allows the transition into completely
different situations after the move a3
you are almost forced to take on c3 and
after b takes c3 or bishop takes c3 now
we get a different brand of positions
which i think it uh was what sam shangri
was looking to get in this game i think
a3 was just a misstep bishop to f8 g3
and now it just feels like black is
doing amazing in the position right now
minus 0.8 it was even worse before that
but it just feels like black has the
easier play queen to e2 i can get the
knight to e4 even bishop c4 bishop to b3
ideas uh are on the board it just feels
like black has a very healthy situation
right now and i just think that sam
shanklin
made a huge misstep with that early move
a3 instead of what i think he prepared
that was g3
sometimes those preparation missteps can
be really really painful what was your
worst
misstep yeah i mean you you come to the
game well prepared you're really really
excited and then you make a failure yeah
i remember yeah very very painfully
we've been discussing it recently uh
on the topic you know of the recently
concluded olympiad and like my my
history over over the course of the very
many olympians i've played right i
remember we played a match against
poland i think or czech republic i
apologize in terms of in 2014
and the entire
coaching team spent like a day preparing
a very very sharp line of the caro for
me
and then i sort of looked up at the for
you know from the board by move seven
and i realized i'm not getting what they
do
because because i absolutely failed to
you know make the right move yeah right
yeah just like move or that eluded me
entirely and you know i've been playing
chess professionally for like 30 years
at that point it really isn't great
awkward moment yeah and i lost i lost uh
horribly to victor lesnich in the match
oh my goodness go well yeah that
probably is considering it was a team
event that probably is the most
embarrassing of all of those that stands
out by the way guys yes lanier still
thinking yeah right now he's down to his
last 14 minutes and he's been thinking
for the past 10 minutes this is
incredible
that's uh after
three
after queen g3 this uh novel idea that
fabi employed in this game
yeah for a lot of minutes almost in the
rapid game and i i want to just briefly
show uh what i think is one of the very
important underlying ideas of these
three here you would like to play f6
here right
and this i think runs into the h6 yeah
this is driving the knight away yeah if
if we could actually kick the knight
away from the e5 square black is this
maybe winning because black is a pawn up
here we have to after all exactly but
you're mentioning bishop yeah we're
playing bishop h6 here and then we get
this weird rook ending after bishop g6 i
think it's a rook ending at least bishop
g6 we take on g6 you have to take on g3
because otherwise it's kind of bad we
take on e7
rookie 7. i guess i take hg i mean
there's some argument to be made for fg
to make our king march towards the
center slightly faster but i think we
still always take to the center right
right we're being taught to always take
to the center this is uh the gods have
told us
and black is still upon up and despite
an absolutely broken up structure i get
the feeling maybe there are some drawing
chances like i can go rugby eight rook
before here for instance
if not for that i think it's resignable
but i have rugby eight room before and
sometimes you don't lose those but
obviously it's not a dream like i will i
will collect a lot of stuff along the
sixth rank exactly now here
i mean it might actually be a draw for
all we know uh hosing of the of the
structure okay that's a
bit but f7 f6 you played f6 by the way
oh okay so a long thing
we might see this entire line up to uh
rook takes e1 and gh and that's why we
will have to if i will have to think
because rookie six is not forced you can
go rookie seven you can go roxy one
there's a number of options there i just
was going slowly through
the progression of our whole line and
when we reached here
let's try that other
alternative uh i'm sure you're sure it's
better though yeah it feels artificial
yeah taking away from the center like it
just it's not it's not amazing okay one
question for you guys can we just go
back a couple of moves yes can we take
on east seven yeah maybe that as well
yeah we just stopped there and this is
what i expected him to ask me yeah like
can we take on e7 here
like how is that engaging
g6 and i take on g7 we exchange
everything and then rook to c1 but what
what what better version or worse
version why do i have to give up the
queen queen h4 yeah that's that's that's
the queen h4 might be a strong move here
yeah specifically queen h4 if not for
queen h4 i think this idea would be
quite interesting but queen h4 appears
to be yeah just dampening our spirits if
you take bishop takes rook to f7 wins on
the spot yeah not getting my bishop back
no
and that was why we were going down this
primrose path
hmm
all right well i mean very very forcing
line and uh and also i think it's an
indication of just how uh
lanier feels about his position because
network ending even if it's holdable
it's never going to be fun for blacks so
if after thinking for 10 plus minutes he
chooses to go for this it's clear that
he respects the novelty a great deal
exactly he's very much prepared to
grovel here
gravel
so sometimes you just need a good grovel
there to to to get into the
into the swing of the tournament
um yeah these double danger ponds none
of this is fun but this looks like it
might be holdable honestly because we
it's
it's very likely
actually yeah i mean three against two
and like on the king on the exactly yeah
i was about to say
not the best two yeah
it always shocked me whenever there was
a three versus two the victor corchine
told me the best two was f7 and f6 i
found that just
mind uh yeah but when you get introduced
to the idea first yeah it kind of shocks
you and then you think about it for like
30 seconds and you realize yeah it takes
away so many squares now the game that
we actually kind of
came into this round thinking might be a
marquee match-up is this one uh the game
between hikara nakamura and mvl again
mvl is in
good position as far as the grand chess
store is concerned
hikaru comes in as a
wild card if you will even though he's
the defending champion of the st louis
rapid and blitz and also
well he was until yesterday the number
one rated player in the world and rapid
but those two losses
gave magnus uh
the first position and after we
saw very volatile it's uh
peter
when i was learning the sicilian h7h5
was never
ever
and now it's getting played in every
single position exactly what's going on
h7 h5
i mean we're still a long way away from
g4 g5 and uh hockey
you think it's that fast
no i mean it's not it's not it's not the
hakai mata that war is black in these
types of positions it's the control of
the d5 square you you need the knight on
f6 to continue fighting for the center
even if you're not getting very quickly
mated once the pawn reaches g5 so just
you're just unhappy about the uh the
fact that it gets there
even though this looks playable frankly
like yeah
just to emphasize what you're saying
it's more of a positional than it is
like i'm going to checkmate your king i
just get my knight to d5 obviously i've
done it in a way you can play bishop
takes g5 but maybe i should have played
rook g1 and or h4 but i understand so
it's a position of uh it's so it's by
this point i think people realize that
it's it's actually a sound positional
idea in a lot of sicilians where people
wouldn't have dreamed dreamt of it uh
earlier and
it's shockingly difficult to refute
because you
like h3h4 prevents you from opening up
the king side for at least quite some
time g3 followed by h3 followed by g4 is
so slow something by this point
something will happen on the other side
of the board maybe rook takes c3 will
rock
so yeah it's it's just become a staple
of
of black's approaches in the sicilian
and nvl i think is
very much sort of on the record
liking these types of ideas in all kinds
of in all kinds of structures and by the
way that was a huge moment or right
there because mvl you don't really have
a lot of options in the position you
cannot really move the a pawn because
that square b6 is becoming extremely
weak after that you don't want to do
that so he decided to simplify the
position uh or at least clarify the
position as much as possible with this
exchange bishop takes d5 but after he
takes d5 now he had the options of
potentially getting knight to b4 and
double attack the pawn on d5 as well as
the pawn on c2 but then there are some
incredible complications after move
queen to b5 attacking and targeting
knight on b4 you have to make a decision
you cannot take on d5 of course after
rook takes d5 this is just completely
losing for black you have to take on c2
the problem is that after bishop to a7
i'm not even too worried about taking
that pawn but rather i want to inflict
some damage on your pawn structure and
not allow you to get the pawns rolling
with a6 and b5 and kick my queen away
right now it doesn't seem like there's a
lot of ways in which you can develop
your pieces as black i'm looking at this
rook on f8 which is pretty much
impossible to get it in the game the
knight on c2 is also a little bit off so
the only way to get back is via d4 but
that loses a pawn so you don't want that
despite the fact that you took this
important pawn in front of my king's
castle you're still not ready to create
an attack a dangerous attack as black
and the position seems to be very good
for
white he played the move knight to a5
what do we think about this move guys g4
and go directly on the attack that's one
option the other option is of course
black is trying to get the knight to c4
and start swarming around my king what
if i just stop it with the move queen to
b5 you don't have the move knight to c4
perhaps you have to exchange on b3 but
this position with the two bishops the
bishp7 is not very active knight on f6
still far away from the center of the
action you're only attacking me on the c
file with one rook i don't see your
attack going anywhere on the queen side
black's attack that is and my attack on
the king side is coming fast i'm going
to go g4 maybe bishop to e2 and then g4
if i manage to open up and queen b5 is
on the board guys i'm starting to like
white's position i have to say yeah i
think i think this got to misplayed
somewhere along the way by by mvl i'm
not prepared to say exactly where but i
don't like this for black very much i
think i mean you're never entirely
hopeless in these types of structures
you can you can imagine how this
position gets improved like if black
takes on b3 and then somehow magically
gets some kind of 97 bishop g5 types set
up
on the board
then you'll have a nice outpost
i must say though uh queen b5 was played
more or less as part of his prep but it
sure felt like g2 g4 might have been
even more challenging how did the engine
is very critical quincy queen b5 at
least according to the engines yeah it
was the best movie in the okay actually
never mind now that i'm looking at it at
a deeper level it does seem like g4 is
favored by the engines as well
complicated situations
really challenging bishop to c1 just
keep the position compact uh have a lot
of defenses uh defensive resources
around my king and then just focusing on
uh killing you on the king side as white
it's looking good for white i have to
say yeah it also looked very promising
and it reminded me of some games i
played uh
when you know the theory of the bishop
e3 on eindhoven was just being developed
and you often got structures like this
not exactly like this because people
haven't really started playing h5 in
those years yet but yeah you you kind of
like this for for white peter aren't you
conflicted as a chess player in the
sense that you play e4 and you crush all
of these sicilians and then when your
opponents play e4 you play the sicilians
and crush
e4 players don't you feel like you're at
a uh
those those days were fun
i no longer can really count myself as a
as a
you know
a sicilian player with both colors even
though i i still do it uh on occasion
but much
much rarer these days than it used to be
when i was a
an up and coming you know right but yeah
it was that was fun yeah playing playing
the night off with both colors and
trying trying to figure out ways of like
dealing with the things you've just
shown yesterday on the other side of it
was
it was always an exciting and exciting
proposition
now queen b5 i've got to ask you peter
once again we're in a kind of it's
fashionakov looking territory but we got
here by a completely different
uh move order uh
if you were to weigh uh a normal special
cough like what we might have seen in
london for example in 2018 in the world
championship is this position honestly
this still looks like a night to me i
think this this this looks like a knight
this looks like a night off to me this
is a very very typical b3 type structure
that there are some things about it
which you don't very often see neither
specifically the only thing that's kind
of alien to a proper night of players
the fact that the knight is on a5 and
the pawn is on a7 but everything else
might be on dc yeah everything else is
very very recognizable as a night off uh
i think christian is correct i think uh
black is so far away from generating any
kind of play on the queen side for for
now that
you you might even have time in this
particular setup to go like g3 h3 and g4
or maybe even just rook g1 and g4 and
just start
opening stuff up on the king side and
that might
create
significant problems for black very very
quickly so yeah and and if i try to
bluff you out of playing queen takes b7
with a move like knight d7 ideas of
bishop g i'm very interested in uh in
queen b7 you know it's
although i'm pretty sure the engine just
grabs b7 and says no mate and then a7
says yeah well what made there's no mate
in chess right right so uh the bluff
would it work oh no christian you got it
you got sam shanklin and uh yeah on your
mind let's jump over to your game i got
a different uh game on my board uh this
is the game that i was saying is going
perfectly for levon ironian with the
black pieces out of the opening but
unfortunately it does seem like white
managed to stabilize the position there
is no more light square bishop on the
board for black and it does seem like
two bishops are going to be quite
consequential in this game after rook
ed1 defending and stabilizing the bishop
on d2 of course this is your main
protector against the pawn on d3 after
the move a6 white has this incredible
move on the board potential knight to g5
knight takes g5 bishop takes c6 you're
going to have to move the rook somewhere
right and then i just simply drop back
bishop to g2 and this seems like a very
very good position i have so many
threats right now with white
taking advantage of the fact that these
two bishops are so active this bishop
despite the fact that right now is
defending against the movement of the
d-pawn i also have the idea of putting
it on a5 and that's going to be coming
with devastating consequences for black
the knight is a little bit off side
right now h4 is a big threat as well you
cannot get it back to e4 because i have
enough defenders so you don't have time
to take on b2 h4 or f4 attacking the
knight and that loses a piece so a very
uncomfortable situation for black right
now if white manages to find this move
knight to g5 big moment in the game for
sam shanklin but i have to say that it's
honestly shocking that they have played
bishop takes e2 there i yes
he's just not playing or not playing
well so far i think when he's on form
the i think the move bishop takes you
two would just not occur to him in this
position like
you're you're just doing such a
disservice to your position by by giving
up that bishop and making white's life
just so much easier uh
good to argue two bishop takes e2 was he
fearful then of knight f4 i mean the
knight f4 is one of the best squares in
these types of structures for the knight
but
i mean this idea perhaps he didn't see
bishop c4 but even if you don't see
bishops before i still like i would just
hate the idea of taking only two so much
and i i think he is
uh it's a it's a kind of a
indication that he's not he's not firing
on all cylinders
i think is just never going to be very
good
i mean if you win by force you take on
it of course of course but uh that just
doesn't look right for for for me the
move knight g5 is very surprising once
you see it you kind of go okay i was
like just thinking about the idea
yeah he wants to play queen b5 this is
obviously the idea of isik exactly and
i'm not interested in helping the pawn
structure but i was kind of like
thinking about this one and again knight
g592
uh is still on the table here and the
question is like asset or
no it's clearly it's clearly a weakness
and yeah and this is why i was so
shocked by the decision to capture
because i mean the capturing two was
very clearly connected with this idea of
pushing d4 and d3 but right what
ends up happening is that you lose that
pawn very like
and he by the way
so yeah sam is going to be uh in control
here yeah
pleased with the outcome of the opening
uh again this was the knight g5 line
after a6 knight takes g5 bishop takes c6
on the board
um
yeah well
no time for any uh nonsense here so not
really no the bishop will return to g2
and then as as uh christian was showing
specifically h2h4 is just such an
annoying threat here yes bishop a5 is
also a threat but like combining
you know you need to find squares for
your knight on g5 while also dealing
with all the other stuff that's
happening in the position it's just very
unpleasant and the problem is you don't
have time to go rook to e7 right and
still have that square e6 for the knight
come back to because i have bishop to a5
which wins on the spot
such a difficult position and it does
seem like uh things are things are
exploding everywhere yeah i just noticed
that
she just sacrificed the piece in his
game against shah and
uh
this is now a very suddenly a very very
exciting position to discuss 94 i think
he wants to go knight takes e4 oh no no
no that doesn't work sorry no
so we are here and where's the piece
there is there bank
there's a grippy sacrifice followed by
queen d3 and 94 does look like it might
just be the only move because i think
allowing from the xg6 was checked with
the queen still locked house on a8
it doesn't seem very advisable uh
exactly the queen on a but on the other
hand 94. yeah for a second there i
gotten excited by the idea of thinking
by taking with the knight rook situation
yeah but you do this but hold on there's
a there's a c7 check isn't there yeah
what do you only one only one pair of
rooms get traded this is also what this
is what i blended originally yeah right
gotcha i was originally thinking knight
takes e4 but like you say you trade once
but not twice yeah and allowing queen
takes here and now we have a kind of a
interesting position
because i think if you play a four f two
here white is kind of winning thank you
because queen g5 will be a huge threat
like eventually knight c3 to f4 will
become which raises the question
therefore maybe f4
is it the threat yeah i would like maybe
to play bishop d5 right now okay in
order to maybe yeah exactly i want to
have access to the idea of dropping it
back to uh to f7 if i need to
once again i'm i'm seeing a queen
landing on g6
and i'm just uh
want to make sure he takes d5 here i
think is the as the issue and suddenly
everything got stabilized indeed it did
wow
by the way a huge difference on the
clock and shakriar is really shack as we
like to call him is really in the think
tank yeah but i i think jan today has
been uh you know he's been showing a
very very good prep very i think uh he
today is actually the case where he's
playing fast because he he knows what
he's doing right there was definitely
some you know
bishop d5 as you prescribed
it it feels logical because the queen on
e8 has to be included and you're
creating squares for it perhaps queen b7
could be a follow-up
solidifying a position a little bit
if i can be yeah yeah yeah
he's generous now pause for a moment
because i still somehow that knight
takes d5 moment yeah it might actually
it's probably winning material now right
so like roxy two rook c2 right rook
takes c2 and knight takes before i guess
yeah i was going also green g5 but i
don't think it's made right i think it's
oh it might be a professional yeah it
might be perpetual but not made but that
days before is a very solid option here
especially as queen g5 is our uh mustang
g5 as
instantly goes g3 g4 so jan has
a very different approach to this he
wants to play g4 h takes g i assume kind
of is needed
and now we can maybe even just go knight
takes g4 and then f5 queen h6 will be an
additional threat
um
and it feels nasty yeah it reveals very
nasty actually how bad is it uh
christian this move g4 it's really bad
yeah it's really it's really bad yeah
white is just completely winning right
now it seems wow he's blasting uh
through also this knight on e5 is just
an amazing piece it's going to be very
very difficult not only that okay you're
blasting through but you're also opening
the file for the rook to get to g2 right
that might be very strong that's another
uh improvement in your position after
that i can follow it up with king twitch
to get the other rook to uh g1
if i manage to get to g6 your king is
dead so you cannot let me do that but
how do you stop me from doing that i
just see this uh as a one-way street in
this one but take a look at what's
happening in the nakamura versus mvl
game because this has changed
dramatically as well we left it off
somewhere around here after bishop to f5
g6 the problem is bishop to f5 i think
was a bit slow what the engine was
recommended was just simply g4 follow it
up try to open up the position and get
to the black king with this move g4 he
did not do that he played the move
bishop to f5 hunting some pawns but
missed a very important detail and that
is this move b6 very very important
you're going to be upon uh down as black
in the position no matter what you do
but what you have to do is also open up
the lines in the variation that you're
going to follow with bishop takes b6
rook to b8 a4 i have to defend that
bishop somehow because bishop to d8 is
coming and i'm going to lose a piece if
i don't have the a pawn defending it
this is exactly what happened everything
is forced but right now despite the fact
that white is a pawn up i have so much
activity as black i can swing from the b
file to the a file and try to get to
your kin as much as possible it does
seem like black has enough compensation
maybe for even an advantage right now so
nakamura is still struggling in this
tournament with his forum and
interestingly uh there are things were
played there are things happening in in
the uh shangland iranian game which i
think require our attention here because
instead of just dropping the bishop back
to g2 sam went for an attempt to win the
game immediately he played bishop by
five after okay six okay 66 bishop a5
yeah which appears to be winning on the
spot but there is this counterplay
bishop d8 now we are currently a full
rook cup but knight h3 check is coming
this has all been played king of king g2
and now black has a choice between queen
f2 and knight of two um
okay
let's see the most forcing force so i'm
guessing queen takes h3 king takes h3
because we have bishop h4 after rook h6
check we aren't actually getting slammed
uh just yeah destroyed because we do
have we do have that uh that resource
and it looks like we're out of checks
any g5 rook takes h4
yeah control of three queen takes f3
mate
yeah so
i'm guessing it's night takes after
okay
and then no i'd kind of like to tickle
the queen if i can yeah but my question
it's it's really weird because please i
think maybe there are other things but
the position that really interests me is
rugby 191
rook b1 knight d1 yeah
oh my goodness i don't it probably
doesn't work but it's kind of a very
cute strange strange looking position
where uh you have to put the queen on
some
weird like queen b3 looks normal right
right and now
i was wondering if i can just take on c6
and then start pushing but it doesn't
seem fast enough right because you have
bishop a5
or queen a5 if you written in this sort
of i see yeah i was like you can start
with d2
instead of rotation yeah uh f3 and do
exactly the same thing d1
and then
and then that's very good that is cute
that is very very cute
so that in this case you do when you
play rook d6 my queen isn't honestly
this looks like a drawing this looks
like sam may have
one on a6 yeah but i play c4 c3 right so
queen a4 with a con d8 queen takes a6 if
white stabilizes here if let's say if
the opponent's over on a4 here maybe
it's gone the game probably is over yeah
but i place you through c4
and you've got your own runner yeah and
i think a4 c3 doesn't really look to me
like it's a winning attempt to be honest
i don't i don't think right now
queen
c6 yeah 26 uh
even rook d tour k2 i think is a draw i
think you want to play queen c4 because
i think stopping me from getting to a2
is crucial but queen c4 you have rook a8
uh yeah but then i don't threaten
anything i don't threaten c but maybe
rook a5 rook c5 is a threat here yes yes
yes and and obviously the the point
we're trying to make here is that if
it's three against three on one side
just draw will be agreed without without
even playing it out yeah right by the
way knight takes f2 as you
because queen takes f2 was just a day
yeah it's just one it's one chance so
knight takes f2 and ruby one
on the board yeah we'll be one on the
board and we've reached our
crucial moment um
and there there don't seem to be any
good squares
too it doesn't create a threat right
one
queen is not hanging this is my problem
yeah okay
and then you go bishop
i think we will i think we will drive it
away yeah i think i think my d1 needs to
be played i think needs to
but it very much requires and here you
go
for no you need to see this
g2g one and then exactly because i think
otherwise you might still be lost by the
way guys i think we should move to the
nepal game because i think we're going
to see a resignation in that one soon
all right yeah we'll keep this one on
the burner because it's it's white hot
but the resi
i think they're looking at that open g
file
yeah takes d5 is one of the moves queen
to g5 first and then knight takes d5 is
another one yeah everything you need
any takers for queen h6
i'm sure i'm sure there's a lot of ways
to skin this cat right
this looks like pretty much any any well
we left it we left it at g4
rook g2
and this is how we got oh very very nice
play by
by and look at the time difference right
now yeah he's going queen g5 here rook
g7 knight g5 and i think i think this is
somewhere here shaq will just resign
realizing that he's down a piece and
he's sort of continuing continuing to
get mated unfortunately it's not even uh
good call on the resignation christian i
mean
and levon found the entire thing there's
a knight on d1 already in in leon's game
so i think leon probably is going to
end up
uh
saving his bishop g5 we haven't spoken
about bishop g5 at all which i think is
a critical question here probably we
should yeah
i really don't like rook d6 i think if
we have to play with this knight i think
i think my best drawing chance here is
actually to go h6 g5 h64 g5 and force
you to go into those uh those end games
but this one is much more worrying
because our structure on the king side
got destroyed exactly and now we now we
are no longer absolutely assured except
yeah but we have a passer
and if you get to c3 in your bishop
let's just let's just go c5 c4 here yeah
if you get your bishop to g7 this uh
and the pawns on c3 you've got nothing
to worry about yeah this looks once
again like it probably is holdable at
least on my eyes yeah five rooks
[Music]
you have the c5s i have the c5 square
i'm just going to be using the c5 square
as a way to stabilize and not blunder
anything queen of three rooks i will
just play roxy five against if you was i
was hoping to get but that doesn't
create a mating threat i know i'm just
weird as you know bishop is already i'm
passionate and he has played bishop g5
yeah and again another moment of truth a
critical moment here yeah i really just
like the idea of playing with d6 and
trying to keep that that night of uh
alive because i think it lends us uh
lends us in trouble i don't know exactly
why i but i would mistrust it severely
the one reason why i might like rook d6
is because if i can rescue the knight
with the combination of rook d2 and
knight f2 but there is something scary a
little bit about the uh back rank uh as
well uh christian general did you rescue
it so let's go bishop to f4 maybe yeah
ready to check it looks it looks very
scary i would be i would be
also maybe i can start with e4 yeah
exactly i thought the three four was a
very critical move yeah exactly three
four stopping to check e5 v6 is a huge
threat well in this case then definitely
h6 yeah i think we have to go for this
required
okay interesting interestingly one
disagrees the one goes rugby six very uh
very surprising to me but maybe he is
and now after e4 peter what what would
you rather d4 i guess and we tried to
push c4c3 as quickly as possible
quickly played yeah you reckon rook d4
any queen b8 yeah but then like if i see
falcon b8 or something it just looks
very scary all of a sudden i don't like
this
well we are here we are here
how are the youths
doing uh
christian any action going on between
jeffrey and
plenty of action but this seemed uh like
it has stabilized uh right now uh i do
believe that white was actually much
better at this point after rook the ace
to c1 or d8 knight to e2 a bit of a
backwards move a3 was a big moment right
now just kick the rook away rook to b6
of course c5 you have to contend with
that and after rook takes b3 queen takes
b3 sure you uh take on f4 but i have
ideas of queen to b6 and white is doing
just fine also after rook takes b3 i can
take on d6 which does seem to be giving
white the advantage so a3 was a big
moment he decided to go knight to e2 and
it does seem like black is just getting
enough right now this is the position we
currently have on the board bishop to a6
controlling the c4 square is quite an
important resource for black it does
seem like we have a battle between these
two it's a very sharp position because
very sharp c6 is still hanging like
bishop a6 i understand there must be
some reason why actually the queen
actually gets captured on c6 it's all
burying the lead there a little bit
you're right this is i mean probably
crucial jeffrey's playing fast that's
actually a pretty i i've seen lots of
queen traps but that queen takes c6
ooh d3 gondii 4g3 which is an
understandable idea of you know
including the rook on before in in the
game but yeah knight
c4 queen c5 and then knight jump
somewhere well knight b2 takes d3 is i
mean my bailout option but maybe there's
something more exciting anything no rook
takes d3
c4 followed by knight b2 just seems like
the right approach okay so
yeah this looks this looks promising
because
we are right for white yeah because
we're establishing a lot of control we
we will pick up the pawn on d3 next move
c6 is hanging yeah the bishop one v3 is
much more active than the bishop it just
feels like white's pieces are and that a
pawn in any end game is going to be such
a threat
wow so advantage and we talked about
that coming into this uh particular
round for jeffrey could leapfrog
if he wins if he wins he will be at
least in a tie for first and perhaps
even in in seoul first because
because
yeah linear definitely is not winning uh
mvl mvl's position has become quite
sharp but i don't think he has
legitimate chances to be better just yet
so it looks like if jeffrey wins he
might just be leading the tournament
four rounds in into
our event yeah quincy five has to be
played along
is
tantamount to
oh rook takes d3 right away he hasn't
played knight b2 yeah i liked yeah i
thought 9b2 was
very attractive but
okay
in just 10 minutes it's weird that he
didn't spend a little time
this last move rook before
intimating that ideas of queen f6 or
rookie seven what what did you think
mvl's best move was against i'm not i'm
not entirely sure you would like to play
rk5 but the issue is with the queen on
c3 it's only one check i can play for
instance rookie seven here or queen of
six yeah and they can be one exactly and
then suddenly that's their one check
that's yeah that's the one check and the
there's no follow up
so perhaps you need to spend the tempo
on on stabilizing in some fashion like
queen a7 or something like that like
just
right now here just exercising some
control over a little caution yeah but i
still don't have a good reply to queen
f6 which is worrying me queen f6
introducing absolutely a8 now
because that will not be there
there will not be one check
that will be one and out yeah that would
be a nice checkmate um
rook a8
okay that's as as a suggestion and now
maybe we want to ah okay yeah i blended
okay four okay this was not that great
yeah no yeah not what you had in mind
when you went for the queen a7 so rook
f4 and the clocks if you will seven
against four and a half for mvl so not
really panic stations just yet but uh
hikaru keeping things firmly
and firmly
eight so i'm guessing after queen of six
he wants okay roxy
that's a clever move yeah and if if
you're really forcing rook c4 that
solves most of your issues because if
one pair of rooks comes off you're
definitely not getting made once again
what what's the issue here
when i took the tour
[Music]
he
was aware that rook c8 existed and
has calculated that by the way in that
case rook c8 was a very very very good
move accurate move
uh it's still a sharp position like take
stakes we have we we play uh like
because of the structure being so uh so
asymmetrical this is still a very very
sharp heavy psn game exactly but
obviously it's an improvement for black
because the king on g8 feels a lot safer
now christian i want to uh throw it over
to you and uh what are you well let's
cut your eyes i feel a big one that we
should definitely have our eyes on is
the one between geoffrey and fioria
because it's just dropping to his last
40 seconds and that's huge yeah we
should probably be watching that yeah
that seems like a very good game to just
be watching on full screen did did
jeffrey make the right decision in
playing rook takes d3 as opposed to the
move knight b2 yeah and this is one
thing that he does very well uh knight
to b2 was just fine rook takes d3 was
very close in terms of assessment right
now it was still maintaining the
advantage he doesn't take a lot of time
to make these simple decisions and this
is what he is giving six seconds by the
way extra time
right now yeah and uh yeah you made it
with four seconds three seconds three
seconds three seconds yeah
yes he's not comfortable in the position
right now the best move by the way
knight to e4 but still after queen to f4
i'm still maintaining the tension and
the pressure in the position yeah this
is very clever keeping an eye on the c1
rook meaning that the the knight
continues threatening to jump somewhere
so for example i don't think you can
take on c4 just rook c4 and bishop c4
you're just worse you're not losing but
you're definitely much worse by the way
also queen takes e4 i think is a big one
right
yeah also possible yeah for sure but
even even if this is the best white
house this is extremely extremely
dangerous of like these types of end
games by the way you were talking about
the uh time
control of uh game 25
plus 10 seconds and 10 seconds as being
kind of the luxurious mode for rapid
these 10 seconds they go by really
really really quickly it's very hard to
build up too much time and especially
after a move like queen f4
um yeah my
feeling is this is really very difficult
for farouja so what if you just go back
i think he probably just drops it back
and uh it's right here right now because
the london c4 is spinned along the
fourth now meaning that you don't have
any particularly uh inspiring jumps you
can actually still play knight five he's
on the board
yeah he has to make a move he needs to
make a move quick yeah yeah
he goes back yeah he's going back and
i'd have sex so
once you you can actually play 95 but
there's a number of responses here for
black which maybe are tolerable like
first of all the end game might be
holdable and secondly we can play queen
d6 or queen f8 or whatever and the rook
will be hanging yeah
i see so queen d6 and or i
really paid the edge of calculating rook
take c6 please no
which is why which is why queen just
don't make me don't make me you're right
right right right okay so
aha
and by the way guys uh sam seems to have
uh messed it up
oh no against aronian yes
just start targeting that bishop on c1
where do you put it
wow
king of one played king f1
didn't expect that for some reason that
just wasn't on the radar
rook
there are no particularly good squares
yeah before you can you can get hit by
g5 as well with g5 right exactly
there is one way please to save that
bishop and that is with queen c8
ah what well nice geometry there gf
queen g4 check yeah
very nice geometry but if that's the
best you can get as white i mean that's
not great compared to what you had well
queen if he
g5 is on the board we might queen c well
you have to sequence eight no
yeah one might be two looks legitimately
scary for white like i i'm starting he
could easily lose this game yeah like
can you want to knight b2 on knight f2
like the knight gets over to d3 with
check
and then and then we just continue from
there we'll have like full control of
everything we could take on h2 after is
there a bailout for a white like e6 and
try to get some sort of approach i
should expect the d6 instead of king f1
to be honest
i didn't see any follow-up but i was
saying i like the geometry of queen c8 i
must say yeah with queen g4 check to
take the knight
as a bailout uh
uh
times uh for these players four minutes
for four minutes for each so so so
that's not an issue um not just players
i know have time sorry i just wanted
as we'll keep an eye on this game i just
want to go to
uh what happened after knight f6 nothing
else nothing has happened jeffrey's
actually gone into the tank
um it kind of feels like there ought to
be something
here for white but yeah but on the other
hand material is limited and black's
position is not as you know dis uh
disjointed as all that like if you if
you give black time to play h6 and
perhaps bishop e6 d5 yeah everything
will look hunky-dory but you have to you
have to find something immediately and
i'm not entirely sure what apart from
that 95 move which i i keep on returning
to i really don't see anything that
even creates a wise and now we've got
queen quinn somewhere e3 f3 yes
choose a square and try to pretend that
the balance six is much weaker than upon
b3 in all of these positions well maybe
it is because oh
bishop d5 i was about to play the move
knight takes e6 in response the bishop
takes b3
yeah
there's also bishop d5 instead of bishop
xb3 which is what i thought you were
legit so yeah okay you can maybe start
with this it's a strange position it
does look like white should be a bit
better but
it also feels like
you know you make one minor mistake
somewhere and everything is gone you
you're never going to have any advantage
anymore right and uh sorry i'm just kind
of focusing on rook c7 g3 yeah maybe f3
is not the best square f3 not maybe
maybe f3 is not the best square i was
looking at so all kinds of other squares
g3 queen g3 or queen d2 maybe try to
attack
uh queenie no yeah we yeah 95 played
it's the first thing yeah
must have been calculating exactly this
for the entire time yeah he just
probably just goes queen f8 here right
right 26 yeah yeah you you want it safe
yeah and now let's let's look at the
theory f3 chosen and now yeah there's a
legitimate choice between bishop i mean
i don't know how bishop b3 followed by
c5 loses it looks i was gonna take on no
you you still can't yeah he takes on b3
ab3
why can i take bishop d5 you you you how
many i i've lost too many yeah you've
lost you've lost too many things yeah
yeah a b and c5 all of this is on the
board well if you have queen a3 idea i
have queen a3 at the end and this one
and i don't think why why am i not
playing 98 what are we why are we why
are we trying to to resign instead of
not trying not to curse
yes
correct
correct uh so a b c five on the board
and uh alireza got himself some
some uh
leeway on the clock is up to 23 seconds
not a lot but something
and once again it feels like you know i
get h7h6 in somewhere and start you know
generating count to play with some kind
of queen b8 ideas or something you
you feel like probably this ends up
being a draw but you there are still
back rank issues the opponent's e5 is
awkward to defend like 23 even sort of
straight away like 23 now what what's
the move
exactly rugby five perhaps but it it all
of this looks very very awkward
but it doesn't appear to be losing so
he's gone rookie one which is um
uh an interesting idea hinting at a
summary of a8 uh english uh says not a
threat because i have rook b8 and plays
queen e8 but how do we hang on knight c6
ah nice yeah nice rookie four
you want to go rook a8 uh and after
queen takes a8 97 but
peter uh caught himself and said ah
rookie four
uh stops the connection with the a8
square yeah three minutes four for
jeffrey still and
the knight actually is hanging it has to
go somewhere he might have missed queen
eight and that move rook to e4
possibly yeah possibly
even though i have to i have to ask like
if i if rookie one let's say i go h6
what was the threat i'm not entirely
sure that there was a a massive threat
to talk or to to speak off you still
have rookies thank you i still have
roommates yeah i still have uh okay yeah
okay seven is a very good point here
okay seven is annoying mm-hmm yeah
i missed that i missed that all together
but uh this move queenie eight
you know that's a little bit playing
with fire but if it works it's just
simply yeah that's a very good resource
by ryan reza
i'm struggling to simplify this i'm
struggling to find a way to uh continue
asking questions even queen e3 perhaps
forces rook b5 but the more i look at
positions where i play rugby five the
more i feel that the rook actually
belongs on b5 yeah yeah so you know
we're not we're not unhappy about it no
exactly
um and what do you have first christian
well things seem to be simplifying in
all the games except this one the one
between shankland and aronia so maybe we
can look at that one because it does
seem like shanklin still maintains some
chances to win this one let's take a
look at it i'm i'm very surprised by
that actually
we left it uh we saw the move g5 king e1
gf4 that was a stunner i'm very
surprised we were expecting it's the
best move knight b2 and or knight f2 do
you think that f4 in fact was the best
was the best mission
not rook takes h2 though that was the
wrong follow-up you have to go for the a
pawn with the move rook to a2
i see
rook and after h2 maybe i can save that
a pawn so rook takes and yeah i think
sam now is trying to assess if he can
actually afford to go gf because you can
play queen takes c4 fg3 looks scary but
we do have queen g4 check so we don't
lose but we also don't win because the
king goes somewhere and then uh queen g3
and i assume it's a draw of some sort
uh
but the big question is if if in the
current position we go g takes a four we
allow c4 c3
and with the rook on the second and the
bishop you know
sort of threatening to land on e3 or a3
right yeah but he's gone gf but do i
have queen d3 yeah c3 people he did play
uh c3
by the way yes yeah 232 check you can't
do it immediately you have to do
something else first right
but the idea that well bishop c5 can see
a check so there is no immediate threat
so perhaps white can maybe even spend a
tempo on something uh frivolous like a
four or five or
yeah and in the meantime the the the
kirana dominguez game did end up being a
draw that went into that request
that we were discussing actually
appeared on the board and lanier did
hold it reasonably comfortably again is
a time a factor between sam and lavonna
so what if i try to lose a tempo with
kingston i think xi1 looks looks very
logical yeah but you can also probably
start pushing something in the center
both about a minute and a half okay i've
got an h pawn i've got a passer myself
all right let's go e6
now at least c2 is not coming with the
track e6 and uh does that really have a
threat i'm not sure
you're really playing with five
uh
kicking scene
actually played yeah king so
let's
you want to take that okay i think so
yeah i don't think there was queens
there was king j7 actually yeah quincy
and c4 and pick up the opponent yeah i
mean the h pawn looks like it's going
somewhere but the king is going to be so
open that yeah i don't have i don't have
too much belief in in this position
frankly no i think this one is looking
pretty good um yeah and uh the
the uh
uh fear of game will end in a repetition
very quickly
yeah they're looking around uh well for
for very nicely very nicely held by
alireza who uh
at certain points was yeah he was down
to
single figures on the clock and
well we saw one moment where he played
with three seconds
on the clock and uh going oh it looks
like mvl and hikaru
have
pretty much a dead position as well i'm
not sure how dead this is i mean you you
normally draw these types of positions
but black is clearly uh some way behind
in the race
uh and i mean the opponent six is kind
of scary but yeah it's going to take so
many moves by that time don't i nurse he
actually even just goes g65 says i have
enough time to play c7 rooks here
this is kind of worrying me
this feels like we're playing with fire
a little bit too much so we go c7 i
don't know if you want to go i'm not
sure we need to go c7 there's also rook
e8 right now which forces rook f7 and
maybe this is a better try
yeah i'm after rookie six in that
position i think i can just simply go
rogue c8 and i'm probably
rook c7 king b4
well i'm going to uh nurse made mine
yeah i think i think this probably is a
drawing i'm trying to figure out if
there's some kind of a clever way to
finesse these things but
yeah those extra
little rook checks and stuff again i'm
going to jump back to the game yeah this
is a very crucial crucial moment because
if we can play rook a4 we're completely
fine if we're not losing any material
while playing rook a4 uh we just make a
draw because obviously if the pawn on a3
gets removed from the board then it's by
the way guys this is ridiculous right
sweetheart is actually completely
winning
what
so take a look at the variation let's
let's put it on your board yes sir
watching this yeah c7 and this is pretty
much forced rook has to drop back or
drops back you go rook to e6 to cut the
king
which is kind of like where i was
heading right or you can start with rook
to c3 to force the rock on c8
same yeah that's a much more forcing
idea so i have to play rook c8 and i cut
the king with this yeah and now we're
just counting you go i go king before
you go i go king a5
king a5 it's a check
everything is a check it's a check on
both sides everything is a challenge
yeah g2 rook c1 or king a5 does exactly
rook c1 you cannot go g1 because that's
a check you cannot take on c7 because
that's a check and you just get killed
b6 king to b6 the king yesterday oh my
god
it's over the king
was g5 g5 a mistake you could he have
played something else yes g5 is losing
on the spot
rook to f8 was fine king 2h6
was fine
oh he played rook the e8 the move that
you were attracted to peter
and that it's back to being a drawer yes
yes and now it's back to being
introduced oh with that c7 and rook c3
to c6 that would try the board nice
oh no rook but it's it's such a
non-standard idea to allow actually g2
when your king is still not connected to
the pawn on c7 and you have to realize
that g1 which normally just makes an
immediate draw yeah does not make an
immediate draw because if it's checked
because the king is still on g7 i think
it's it's an understandable mistake it
will it will be you know it will sting a
little bit for hikara when he realizes
because
because of just how straightforward the
entire thing was but peter i see that
more often than not
the double blindness i like to call it
both players understand they trust one
another they see the same things and
they just knew that the variation would
be a draw uh once the pawn gets to g2
yeah yeah i think i think both of them
calculated that and both of them assumed
i'm playing g2 when the king is still on
a5 shake hands but exactly
shake hands indeed but not the way not
the way you wanted
call an ambulance but not for me as my
friends used to say but not for me yeah
so king d5 on the board we're expecting
and that's a done deal actually
that was an exciting game
i must say a very exciting round but
not the route not not not the decisive
uh it seems like we might actually have
only one decisive game in this round if
hikaru doesn't win and higher shouldn't
win from here i think both king of five
and maybe even g5 g4 should be it should
be okay i like king i just don't want to
get too
far removed from the from the pawn
but g4 makes a lot of sense also g4 also
makes yeah because yeah like rookie one
king g5 we sidestep when he checks on
along the f file okay and you cannot
really go king to e4 because rook d7 is
also a move there exactly no i think
this is yeah we we have we have plenty
of them be here we don't even need to be
you know too worried about things
nice three four mvl might have survived
this by the way once again shaq
a player that we're really used to you
know
thinking a
world's top
10 player he's just
slip sliding away he's not having uh
he's not having a particularly stellar
period but it's like the games that he
is losing his opponents are playing
brilliantly like this game that nepo
just played was
was a marvelous game i mean g4 and rook
g2 and all of those great moves that so
it's like sometimes you're just
victimized by
yeah specifically this game perhaps he
was somewhat that prepared and he kind
of drifted into a position which
suddenly became yeah just g3 rookie
three rook gesture king d6 i'm not sure
is he what is what we're trying to
achieve here what what what i mean it's
still it's still a comfortable draw i
think more or less whatever you whatever
you choose to do i would assume
yeah you can just go g2 g2 rookie one
and then rook g7 and then gather behind
root g3 rg3 and start checking yeah
yeah it's so it's not very risky anymore
frankly no nobody nobody's running too
many risks here
that's what he's doing yeah
you just need to have the the check from
from behind uh yeah just just have the
have the uh the checks available from d3
c3 squares exactly i guess rook g7 is a
little bit scary just because you see
you have seven you have c7 yeah but
there's one chick in there g1 is the
point you can go
you can see that c7 g1 is a drawing
right because you got the check on d
yeah so in in that respect rook e7 is
perhaps
an easier move to make on human terms
yeah and this is what he does here
rookie seven uh making sure that the
little gets to each other so rookie one
rook g7 with the rook ether k7 played
here okay one rookie two rook c1
yeah we can start giving checks from
like e6 and so on yeah
so you go all the way to d8 and then you
just simply go to g7
kick the king all the way to d
so that after a c8 you always have root
g8
you know hikaru is actually creating a
lot of issues in what i assumed was just
a very very easily holdable position
here much credit goes to him here he's
not going to win because nvl by this
point realize what is required of him
and he is not going to sleep but
and if you get too far
asking the crucial question he continues
asking you know salient
not immediately obvious questions yeah
rooksy one was a very very nice try
there by
by hikaru
that's what it's all about and king c5
we can even go king e7 if we want i
would assume yeah
king d5 yeah we can give one more check
and after king g4
um
rookie ate even right
wait
by the way with the king on d4 there is
a check right
so we're just looking at yeah we can we
can see
yeah we can actually play rooker 55 c7
rook f1 even though that still is a draw
yeah but turkey sixes
c7 g1 he's he's having he's having some
fun here
c7 g1
rook takes g1 rook c6 and we just win
the seaport that is a nice yeah that is
a nice finish yeah he's still awesome
very beautiful poignant
c7 and now comes the queen that's a
check and instantly hikaru looks around
like what am i doing i'm an idiot i
missed but it was it was a draw here it
was done
don't be so distraught exactly i think
he knows it was a draw yeah he probably
has has a pretty good idea he wasn't
actually winning there
and yeah well as as professionals these
days
he's not still taking on c7 yes
whoa
oh he was winning there he was winning
there for one move but he was like he
was a draw
at the very end prior to that so right
so
where with the replay with the magic of
television half a minute this was the
moment
where the where the move rook e8
actually blundered away the wind
that moved c7
uh breaking the rules so to speak
christian that would have what that
would have
that would have shocked it requires
calculation which chicago definitely
doesn't uh lack the ability to calculate
everything the problem is you don't
expect it right right the only position
that loses of the king is with the king
on g7 right that's probably the only
square
that's the worst square in the position
yeah so that both g one you don't think
seven you're not even looking for it i
guess it's uh it's what hikaru missed
yeah so we we do have only one decisive
result in this round and alireza is
still at the top there on uh six out of
eight uh with the win uh over shakira
manjarov yani coming she joins the tie
for second so it's now second through
the fifth
uh a four-way type of second samsung
london four draws out of four is in
clear sixth and then we have three
people on minus one and chocolatier is
continuing to have a very poor
tournament so far one out of eight for
him and we had anastasia catching up
with nepo
after his very nice victory in this
round 4. take a
and look on the victory against shakur
good start of the day actually yeah
better than yesterday but it's still a
few more games today the place
that's for sure but it doesn't happen
that often to create such a great attack
against shakhiar who is famous to be one
of the most active players in the world
how was it today
yeah i think the structure just really
favors white is
uh it is nice if i thought it posed for
my knight and his bishop on b7
probably remains
passive throughout the game and yeah it
was
i think was quite unfortunate decision
for him to shuffle his queen to a8 so
basically queen didn't take any part in
the in into the game so i think it's
i mean anyway it should be better but
when i saw this bishop g6 i was like
quite
you know
i was excited so it's just for an sad
and then coming d3
hopefully it's
you know as good as it uh as it really
seems to be but uh yeah if not then
and whatever then okay i tricked him
yeah there was many times you could push
g4 in this game but you were trying to
you're not doing this move
did you consider it at any moment yeah
obviously at every moment but the
problem that
if i played g4 after he played h5 it's
some kind of an issue that he takes and
gets e4 outpost for his night so still
is quite nice for me but i wasn't sure
if i want this and uh to give him
counter play
and somehow combine move a friend of g4
would be an ideal scenario for me but
i didn't see if
i could do this but
yeah i mean i'm still
you know
still studying uh
catalan type of positions so it's a
very nice experience yeah for sure and
how do you feel yourself here in saint
louis
well with every next day after i arrived
it was quite quite quite a journey like
30 hours
i would say yeah so
i know it takes some time to recover and
uh
yeah overall i think
it would be even better to you know
arrive here like do this earlier but
yeah hopefully i'll
yeah
my schedule will will be more or less
normal closer let's say to the classical
part for sure thank you so much and all
the best of luck in the next round thank
you
a very nicely played game i think
as usual he's setting himself short
there saying that you know i tricked my
opponent there
by playing against the clock or whatever
he played a very very nice catalan and
he appears to be enjoying his you know
new new life as a as a catalan player
i don't think he's been a catalan player
for long but so far it's uh it's a very
very nice change of pace for him and he
seems to be really enjoying these types
of positions learned a lot of lessons
from dubai uh quick thoughts uh
christian as we get ready for our first
break of the day well precisely he faced
the catalan with the black pieces now
he's definitely enjoying it playing with
the white pieces and if you are the
field and if you know how streaky jan
can get and you see him string some
wings together well you start worrying
about your situation in the tournament
and this is exactly what we're seeing
right now from definitely looking
forward to the next few rounds
absolutely we'll see you all on the
other side of the spring see you then
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages
vip tickets and more available now at
ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to day two of the saint
louis rapidom blitz and here are the
standings after uh the first round today
uh as you can see only one decisive game
there young homie should be using
shakira
and joining this huge pile of
pile of poisoning wolves i want to say
chasing alireza who who made a
reasonably solid draw against jeffree
strong jeffrey did have chances but they
resonated very very nicely and saved
that game so still plenty to play for
and uh one person clearly uh so far very
much out of form uh shakti one
one point all the way i just wanted to
say that mvl
dodged a bullet as hikaru did have that
one one window of opportunity
to climb back and get a 50
with a victory mdl however standing
nicely which dovetails into our grand
chess tour standings and why for mdl
uh fighting for these points is so
critical uh peter yeah as you can see uh
wesley is at the top there with uh a
cool hundred grand in prize money and uh
22 and a half logicity points but he's
already played the two rapid events
exactly he's not playing here
and uh both mbl and livon on 19 points
have a very very decent chance of
actually overtaking him before the start
of the final event of the tour which
will be the sinkhole cup right
coming up shortly uh levon is not having
a stellar tournament so far even though
many things will still
change most likely but mpl is going is
doing well and it does look poised to
perhaps
uh assume the yellow jersey of later
exactly for fabiano those 13 grand chess
poor the grand chess tour points would
certainly be nice because of our
upcoming event peter yeah and this is
what what's in front of us uh after the
wrapping blitz is over the sinkhole cup
starts almost immediately afterwards
daddy at the moment all in the final
grand chess tour event itself with the
uh opening ceremony and drawing of lots
on the 31st and i think the first round
on the second not on the 1st of
september if i remember correctly all
righty then the ultimate moves on
september 13th
and then we uh play some some 960 some
light 960 entertainment for for your
view
random but for those of you who don't
know ultimate moves is the contest
between team rex
and team randy where uh team rex and
randy uh go head-to-head and all play
all kibbitz uh brawl absolutely and then
and then there's the the national
championships which will be held uh as
usual in saint louis uh in october
starting from the 3rd of october and
running
up until
the 20th both the us and the u.s women's
chess championships wonderful upcoming
events and our pairings for round five
peter
yeah here we are uh two people tied for
second there lanier dominguez with the
white pieces against the initiation the
leader is playing against fabi fabi uh
you know that would be always a game to
watch but five is having a bit of a
struggle yeah i mean he is not doing so
poorly because he's extremely resilient
he saved some poor positions already but
yeah not not his best event so far levon
is white against jeffrey shang uh mvl
plays against uh sam shankland and
hikaru
or hikarma jaraf is a
is a pairing with both players really
looking to uh
score and again uh this is a
a
a match-up from the uh candidates that
was uh recently played
there in madrid but it just feels like
it's such a different moment than the
candidates itself uh it's going to bug
me if i don't now mention this but that
hikaru mijara thing it reminded me of
one of the all-time favorite soviet
jokes which ended in a punchline of
somebody saying i've just found out that
karl marx and friedrich engels are not
men and wife they're actually four
separate people
so uh
with this out of the way
i'm glad you got that off your chest
yeah it
[Laughter]
my life is now complete absolutely yeah
and uh they are off uh and uh away they
go uh quickly we've got a
anti-berlin but
with
nobody this is still this is still a
very very uh well-known position
where uh
as usual these days you can play bishop
g5 and have a very very sharp game on
your hands or you can play something
like rookie one on ibd 2 or h3
all of these moves are very very
playable and also lead to a lot of
reasonably well known theory there's
a
subtle difference with differences
between all of these things and what did
he choose he did play bishop g5 which is
what we would be like as viewers because
this definitely leads to the sharpest
positions
with g5 bishop g3
and both players are taking great
strategic risks this is this is
definitely what you what you like if you
want a very very fighting game
um
what's your take on all of these um
i want to say uh joko pianos
doesn't your brain just kind of turn to
mush after a while you see all of these
variations and somebody says to you oh
first played between vladimir kramnik
and vishyananda you have no idea
yeah this is this is not the jaco piano
but you do get the right pianos as well
so i understand why you're asking it in
uh in this way right uh all of these
positions in particular
these types of positions with the bishop
you know spending a lot of time to to
get locked in on g3 right i
i think we had this discussion on air
even and it's a very it's a very kind of
a typical discussion between two
all-stars you know right i was brought
like when i was a kid i would
immediately assume i'm better here with
black this bishop on g3 is horrible i
will eventually have some kind of an
attack on the king's side either with h5
h4 perhaps the knight will go away from
f6 and i will push f5 and i'll have a
fantastic position
in these days uh like all of this
it's not that black doesn't occasionally
get very good positions in these types
of lines but the understanding of just
uh how much play you can get in the
center here for white has become
a lot more detailed and people
go for these types of positions a lot
happier than uh they would have um
ages ago uh christians jump right in
yeah i'm very curious to see what
fabiano is going to come up with in this
position he played the move knight to h5
and i was looking through the top
games in this position and there's
actually one karwana versus howell from
2021 so fabiano has played this position
with the white pieces that one went this
way knight to h5 knight to d2 queen to
f6 as you guys were mentioning it's all
about this break in the center d4 has to
come for white at some point to put
enough pressure in the center to
destabilize black's position otherwise
i'm just simply going to go knight to f4
rook to e8 and i'm going to have a very
healthy situation d4 take on d4 and now
e5 this was the position very
complicated battle but definitely this
allowed fabi to know how to react also
with the black pieces this is exactly
what we're seeing happening right now
it's going to be a very interesting
theoretical battle
tell us uh how did that game between
david howell for pardon me fabi and
david uh finish
well it was white who was victorious so
fabiano actually won that game this
position queen to g7 take on d4 and it
does feel like white is gaining uh
control of the position you can take the
bishop and it does feel like the queen
on g7 not very well placed you will be
able to take on g3 but i even have ideas
of potentially taking with the f pawn
now that there are so many weaknesses
you play the move g5 this square f6 is a
huge weakness in your position so you
have to find something active as black
potentially f5 at some point but it's
not as easy to make that happen so this
is exactly why i think fabiano has
something extra prepared in this game
let's keep an eye on this one
thank you for that christian and that's
exactly what i mean peter i mean this
very important game between
fabi and david just kind of disappears
into the myth but yeah it's like the
awareness is there
and then it's gone
i would
i would disagree with you here because i
would say that the awareness wasn't even
there we didn't get the step one before
we got to step two it disappeared
we even got to speak for yourself yeah
thank you very much i will i will i will
for now
let's just
go around the horn and see what else is
happening uh once again it looks like
one of those
no it's not yes it's the very very
topical petrov that uh has been young
has been playing very so
steadfastly ever since his match against
magnus and in the position of the queen
be three queen d7 i believe uh fabi
played knight h4 against jan and this is
in the candidates and got a very very
good position arguably a winning
position at one point right but the move
doesn't win and uh no it works very well
as a as a surprise for the first time
you play it but you you don't really
expect to have it any anywhere near as
much impact if you repeat it which is
why uh uh linear is uh doing something
slightly off-beat and something
different with a3 and i remember calling
the action in that candidates after
knight h4 when we
were all sitting there built ourselves
up saying you know fabi will find
something to finally put the kibosh on
the uh petrov and no i mean you're right
he did
it
but it wasn't yeah he speak from the
opening yeah he the the thing he missed
wasn't uh wasn't immediately obvious
yeah it's hard to criticize him for not
finding it immediately but
he was at one point clearly uh doing
quite well in that game so a3 is i think
basically just a passing move i don't
think you can describe it as much else
you
you aren't really creating any new
specific positional ideas and
here you're just
in some cases it will be useful not to
have to worry about knight a69 before
right but those are
edge cases which i don't think you have
to think about too much
it's just a move which says to black
please show me exactly how you're
planning to develop from here and uh
judging by the speed of jan's reaction
he does have uh some idea very quickly
playing
takes takes b5 bishop
play the devil's advocate that's a very
strange setup that black has i mean the
queen on d7 kind of interfering with the
knight the knight on e4 no longer
protected i think the point here is that
after bishop d3 we can just play knight
f6
just simply
i'm not i'm not hugely in love with this
but i think that probably is the point
and if you have to take on a five here
uh i will have that yeah okay so let's
go knight g5 here
knight d5 okay the knight on b8
bugs me a great deal yeah me too i was
trying to exploit the fact that well
that's just not the
the brightest uh square are we missing
some tactics of the bishop d3 is there a
way to perhaps maybe the idea is to play
sometimes the idea is to play b6 but
here it really doesn't look right yeah i
was actually uh hoping to get in the
move queen c2 after for example rookie 8
queen c2 or suddenly black's position
looks very fragile yeah
your knight f6 was okay yeah i think
knight f6 is probably the way to go but
after bishop g595 that position i'm
as long as we don't take on f5 and give
black that very nice square on d7 for
the b8 night let's say we go knight bg2
even some something slow like knight bg2
here planning to go knight d4
looks to me i'd be reasonably happy here
with white i think i think so too uh
instead of our recreating
opening theory christian could you help
us
clarify the game between lanier and jan
uh the the the capture the team and the
five looks strange yeah and you guys
actually went through the right
continuation bishop to d3 knight to f6
bishop to g5 was the right move but now
the computer is starting to say some
weird stuff uh bishop to h4 which is not
a human move i would assume what he's
trying to do is go bishop to g3 later on
and try to take full control of the e5
square after the exchange of the dark
square bishops saying that black doesn't
really have a lot of things to do in the
meantime specifically because this
knight on b8 doesn't have the d7 square
to jump to
i don't think you want to take on d3 it
just feels like this helps me a little
bit knight wave 6 f6 are not good
looking moves this is what i'm worried
about black's position nevertheless
bishop to h4 is such a counter-intuitive
move not only that you want to play the
move bishop to g3 but also you're giving
away this f4 square so you see
something's landing on f4 some tempes
knight to f4 nevertheless that don't
seem to be giving black as much they
don't have enough resources to create
any problems on the king side very
intriguing position and by the way um it
does seem that after queen to f6 alireza
is still thinking in this position
already down uh six minutes on the clock
and i was looking through the lines as
well and through the games and there is
another one howell on the black side
once again against one peter svidler
with the white pieces maybe you remember
this game uh peter you played i was i
was completely posted at one point
you were indeed you were busted but you
won
that game maybe you can explain the
nuances of this move into h i played
horribly yeah the nuances are very
simple i just played that game horribly
uh please don't remind me
you've already forgotten as you
mentioned earlier yeah and finally
alireza does go d3d4 returning us to the
somewhat more trolling path of the um
actually that's a different move order
because
after he takes d4 bishop takes e6 black
will have the option of detecting c3
yeah that looks like mistake to me that
yeah uh finger failure if you want to
play
d3 d4 uh first toss in the move bishop
c6 the difference
you are
allowing
this perhaps here he thought he has
something here like e5 but the five even
gta xe 5 hp5 queen c6 is playable
potentially and by the way you can start
taking on g3 first yeah we can also yeah
we can also definitely include let's
take g3 first take advantage of the fact
that if you basically have pawn i take
on c3 with a check
i think eg ed bishop takes c6 and then
knight takes g3
hold on sorry say that again take on d4
take on c66 and now they now take on g3
that looks like the most forcing and
accurate and i think you probably have
to take with the h1 yeah you cannot
allow me to take on c3 with the chat now
d takes and now d takes exactly that
side steps all that e5 nonsense
yeah we still have e5 but i think
g594.c6
solves
whatever whatever issues we we might
have there with black we are currently
three pawns uh cool
i mean
some of them some of them will get one
back but like we have three up
that sounds like a lot uh
he took on g3 first
immediately i think that's also fine it
does look like it does look like it's
also fine i don't see anything
particularly wrong with it
i cannot take with the f-bomb i don't
think fg is a fg is still a problem yeah
this looks also like silliness why are
we
playing d4 to play d takes e5 so it
seems like fabiano is uh trying to
potentially having some decent chances
and there's a actually all of this has
been seen in the game between uh uh
denis boris and nicholas some some years
back i just saw it on yasser's screen
um which i think ended in a draw but it
doesn't look good at all for white it
looks like
something has gone
off the rails yeah a bit wrong for um
wow okay
we'll keep an eye on that uh let's jump
to levon versus
nothing going on here between jeffrey
and levon we have we have three very
cool potentially very quiet games uh
apart from the two that we've been
discussing so far we have this uh this
line that i sort of described as the
better off of the one default opening
exactly uh between uh
and hikaru uh both playing uh quite
quickly chakri are actually seemingly
better prepared than hikaru for this
game because he is playing faster but my
assumption always is that it's it's a
little bit better for white but should
be holdable and i think experience shows
that black rarely loses these types of
positions exactly as you said though and
that would have probably yeah you will
and then we have the rookie one and
berlin in the game between mbl
and sam shanklin which is actually a bit
of a striking thing for to my eyes
because
mvl i think was maybe the last remaining
uh you know warrior on the side of
i will play the end game and i will beat
you in the end game he won a number of
very very
nice games on the white side of exactly
the classical berlin
ending yeah but today he is choosing not
to question sam
uh on the intricacies of of those
positions and yeah this is something
that people do occasionally uh these
types of positions if black is not
entirely precise you can definitely uh
you know imagine let's say the rook's
coming off the queen's coming off and
then you have the bishop pair against
the bishop and knight yeah you're not
much better but you're definitely a
little bit better and you can torture
uh much more importantly and enjoy the
position now the knight on d6 i was
about to say before the move knight f5
was played makes a strange impression
it's not doing it
but knight f5 certainly seems uh and
then there's this petrov that you
mentioned in the game between levon and
and jeffrey which
i mean i'm not sure i agree with your
assessment that nothing nothing at all
is happening here because i was
wondering what the next move for black
is because i don't think you can play
knight e6 i think allowing this exchange
of the exchange sacrifice for the rookie
six and quinta h6 is very dangerous
bishop f6 looks
maybe bishop f6 but it does look a bit
suspect and maybe i can start hoping to
push some h4 h5 somewhere
so i would i would like to say that
maybe white has a pull yeah we we still
we still are some moves away from black
completely neutralizing our potential
initiative here true true
uh although
as usual with these types of petrovs
yeah that's uh by the way the
yeah jess is a fun game absolutely and
he's a
fan and he seems very content uh
whatever's in that uh
we we gotta bottle it and uh what do you
got first christian well i was looking
at this game moment the arrow versus
nakamura i left it a while ago because i
don't think anything will happen in this
end game it's considered to be quite
easily uh equal from the black's
perspective but right now what we're
seeing in the position he can't play
this move f5 assuming that maybe knight
to d6 is the natural response but then i
have this extra square e7 if you do take
on b7 this knight is not going anywhere
it does seem like black equalizes maybe
even gets a better position in the
ensuing complications now the problem is
that white doesn't have to move the
knight they can even start with the move
a3 which happened in the position and
right now hikaru is realizing that he
might be much worse because after bishop
to e7 knight to d6 this is a very
different position there's no more king
to e7 move forcing the knight to move
and take on a b7 potentially allowing
black species to get into place so right
now after knight to d6 you don't want to
see this on the board this knight
doesn't seem to be going out anytime
soon unless you want to lose a pawn and
obviously you don't want that that's
going to give white a tremendous
advantage in the ensuing for rook end
game this is what i'm seeing right now
a3 if you do take on e4 once again still
the same problem remains how do you get
your pieces out the knight on b8 is
problematic
also after you take on e4 your structure
is completely shattered i'm going to
follow it up rook to e1 pick this pawn
on e4 out and then it just seemed like
white is having a very very uh
significant advantage in this end game
i'm not liking what hikaru is doing
right now against mamedyarov
and he doesn't look
either uh christian yes absolutely and
there's uh there's been breaking
developments in our petrol between uh
lanier and uh and ian nipomnishi did
something that we didn't really think
was great he took on africa and in that
he provided the knight on b8 with a
square on d7 but
jan and his eagerness to actually play
97 here i think he may have
misunderstood uh the situation 95 flight
is better but the issue is not 95
actually the issue is 94. and if you
make one more normal looking move like
bishop c7
94 wins the queen
oops uh that came out of nowhere but
yeah uh linear did not did not see that
because he he obviously is quite happy
with the end game that he will be
playing right now like that takes d5 is
a very human reaction to what uh to what
jan has done 95 we take the queens off
we go bish p7 uh we win the control over
the
one of the two open files the rook is on
the seventh i must say i was eager for
this as well why is very clearly better
right but 94 was
kind of a harsher reaction to what jan
has done it was
i mean it's a very
picturesque queen trap because i mean
out of nowhere seemingly nowhere i want
to say knight h4 just comes and it's
like and stunningly traps the best the
best black has after let's say bishop c7
knight h4 is actually queen e6 knight f6
and then taking on f6 and it's a
resignable position right you're among
the queen for it's just it's just a
resignable position with the pawn on b7
maybe you could have made an argument
but with a c6 pawn also extremely weak
you're just going to lose
so
you've had the engine suggests you can
play h6 weirdly
h yes i take g6 queen g6 and you don't
have to resign just yet but
weirdly yeah but not the xf7 for
instance that is a pawn that's just a
healthy extra pawn and membership for
bishop g3 like it's just bad for black
honestly wow uh but what he did was such
a human-like reaction absolutely and
this ending
it just feels like i mean
anatoly karpov would be you know in his
glorious element
in these types of endings where he's got
a nibble and i do have to say that
because there is counter play connected
with knight c4
it might not be as
glorious as we all are trying to to sell
to our viewers so to speak it doesn't
look lost for black but
it still is of course very very pleasant
we can also go rookie eight currently
right because the thing is jan is
selling something as well because he
hasn't spent a single minute on his
clock up to this point before the move
knight to e5 he had 25 minutes on his
clock right now it's his first thing is
he bluffing again this is very
reminiscent of what he did against uh
fabiano caruana and he was much worse in
that game
so i think
we've seen him do this before it's not
it's not it's not a bluff
or is it
i think he just likes playing quickly
and he trusts in his uh you know in
particular he won a very nice game in
round one so
i think
it's kind of natural for him to just
sort of trust his hand
because you know his autopilot is
stronger than most people's other pilot
when he's playing well
very very important proviso there when
he when he's playing well his autopilot
is extremely strong but
does seem like maybe 94 was missed i
don't think we are
yeah i really don't think this was prep
and some kinds of positions of 94 are
manageable i really looked horrible too
for black and there's the emphasis on
the clock uh 24 minutes
uh to essentially half lanier having uh
the 12
uh playing quickly
and playing against you know like
everybody in the tournament has their
own kind of cadence their their their
their move
and we're pretty much on
the same levels maybe hikaru stands out
as well
but then suddenly you play somebody like
yeah and that's putting you on your back
foot by playing instantly instantly
instantly and it gets aggravating it
does put you under a lot of pressure on
the clock because you uh you're kind of
torn between trying to maintain that
pace because you don't really want to be
like five against twenty later in the
game that's right that sounds very much
fun
well i mean here in this end game we
don't really care if you have questions
it's such a such a safe ending but in
general
it's it's obviously an issue that you
need to uh
accustom yourself to right so yeah i
mean
it's risky because obviously if if
something misfires if you miss something
uh
yeah it's okay in a completely lost
position it will not help you that you
have
25 minutes against seven or whatever
right but um
in even
complicated positions that time
can't can be a factor absolutely yeah
and uh and yeah i think is very uh very
accustomed to
to this kind of uh approach to uh
playing in particular in rapid that's
what he did in the last game let's not
forget he had 20 minutes against one
minute against the fast player mamadiaro
yeah so that was just a ridiculous
display of speed and another situation
in which it does seem like the times are
very relevant is the game between
fabiano and ali reza because arie reza
is spending a lot of his time right now
he's down to his last
10 minutes if i'm not mistaken
10 minutes and 52 seconds and fabi has a
great position in 22 minutes yeah i
think he's got the two bishops versus
you can also take on c3 i don't think
there's much when you're taking on c3
yeah and along with the
the edge on the clock comes the edge of
material queen takes e3 and
yeah
this clearly is not going uh going
according to plan here for for our
tournament leader no uh do you like
queen g7 or do you like just hanging
queen of six i i'm not really worried
about e5 i think i can play queen f6
provoke e5 play queen f5 and say thank
you very much for the diagonal for
ambition v7 bishop right
every
these bishops look wonderful just simply
absolutely wonderful
so queen takes c3 and
well
this is what happens
when you misfire a key move
in these types of things he didn't play
bishop c6 he played d4 right away and
he's got himself well dare i say it into
a lost position yeah it's a it's a bad
position yeah yeah you probably you're
not overstaging things too much when you
call it lost it does look quite bad
right and
it's quite surprising because it did
feel like this was quite the topical
line and fabiano actually played it
himself with the white pieces you played
it as well peter so it's not like some
obscure line that alireza shouldn't be
aware of um and he heard so quickly
with that move d4 early move d4 just
giving up upon what happened there yeah
it's so it's a strange mistake because
really you know the refutation isn't
some kind of you know you just played
normal chess
c6
yeah
um in the game between levon and jeffrey
zhang you were saying that well maybe
the 96 yeah but things are coming out of
the corner i like quincy yeah queen c8
was uh maybe an accurate move there and
he followed up with knight c4
now he got in 96 not allowing the rook
takes e6 and suddenly black's position
feels a lot
more breathable absolutely this looks
this looks now you know if we assume
that some sort of gtx5 change of
structure although levon has different
ideas and
uh 93 does look like maybe you're trying
to bail out a little bit or maybe not
maybe it's maybe he's still playing for
an advantage i was going to say if you
go let's say dc5 bishop takes c5 it
starts looking like some kind of a 92
fringe right and the kind of a 92 french
where black has zero problems right and
perhaps could start playing for an
advantage at some point exactly and uh
after knight e4 i'm assuming i'm
capturing on d4 that takes d5
oh you just think about this i'm pretty
sure this is the plan i'm pretty sure
it's not see the xd4 no of course no
then in that case excuse me yeah and if
you take only three i think with the
rook you take on d4 i think with the
pawn and
if i already have the bishop
that was my hope yeah right i'd be uh
home and drive absolutely maybe we can
still go bishop six even here though
and
rook c3
the point about the bishop one of six
that we're
so so obsessed about is that we need the
g7 square for the queen you're right and
we need to have an answer to 95 exactly
okay we'll definitely keep an eye on
this one christian uh what's caught your
attention well the situation for hikaru
seems to be getting from bad to worse
because right now he's upon down and i
don't see the compensation in the
position rook ab8 was his last move
right now mamedyarov has the option of
potentially getting knight back to d6
that's going to still allow him to
maintain that extra pawn or go for an
even more aggressive rook to d7 this
allows some complications
knight to d4 but i can just sidestep
this uh dangerous file the b file with
the move king to a2 and you still don't
have a clear follow-up if you have to
make moves such as h5 as black and not
do anything try to restore the material
balance then you're kind of in trouble
i'm going to be a pawn out forever it's
not looking good for hikaru also on time
12 minutes for hikaru 18 minutes for
mamedyaro ficaru is playing at a pace
that he's not accustomed to he's usually
accustomed to uh being on top in terms
of his clock management we don't see
that from him in this tournament
and also first of all i love the move
rook d7 i'm not quite sure i understood
that idea behind knight d4 what's the
movie you have to it's just a move yeah
because after rook this one what's up
what am i gonna do you would love to
have knight e5 unfortunately i just
simply take on e5 and take on e7 and
that's just game over that's for sure
you don't have that square for the
knight i think rookie 7 basically just
makes the threat of 96 much stronger by
taking away the c7 square from the rook
i think this is
apart from activating your rook you you
are now extremely happy to play 96 next
move if it's so forcing bishop takes d6
as a response i get it and that's just
lost yeah and rook d7 just
my goodness that looks really good and
again just rook d7 knight d4 rook d1
are you gonna go knight b5 is that the
idea probably yeah you probably have to
yeah none of this is
happiness
no because you know this is enjoyable
you're doing it
with a pawn down as well so oh boy
well for shaq for both of these players
they're looking for a result let's just
put it that uh that way
and for shaq uh that would be
very very meaningful yeah a very welcome
uh break from
how the tournament started and vale i
think is getting somewhere because he
managed to open up the structure on the
queen side a little bit where he left it
at knight f5 if he went a4 b4 here uh
sam chose to take and play knight h4
seemingly creating some threats but
after queen f4 no threats really
materialize another queens will come off
and uh white's got the ending that he's
been trying to achieve uh yeah i mean
the big question is after let's say
queen of six rook f6 uh we don't need to
pay attention to threats of let's say
knight takes g2 and rule g6 and so on
but i think i can play f3
because if you take with the bishop i
think bishop e1 wins material
if not if not for that
that's a nice hidden resource because
all of those knight g2
are now going to be met by bishop g3 as
well yeah i think i think a lot hinges
on whether my calculation here is
correct but if it is and black just has
to play the same game it's not
well you can't find it yeah but i get
kicked back too i mean in one day uh
something nasty followed by a5 or
something could easily be happening
there's a weakness uh suddenly
appearance
uh
looks like mvl is putting together a
significant advantage
we'll keep an eye on that one too again
back over to you uh christian what do
you have for us well definitely this
ferruja game versus fabiano fabiano is
putting a lot of pressure on furuja and
he's actually finding the best moves in
the position not only that you're a pawn
up but right now i also stabilized it
felt like this [ __ ] pawn c5 was a
little bit tender look to see one
followed by e5 there were some tactical
motifs in the position we don't see that
anymore for white so right now you're
upon down you're facing the onslaught
that is coming on these two diagonals
the bishop on b7 is an amazing piece all
i have to do is try to displace this
pawn on e4 with maybe even a potential
f5 at uh times rook to e8 followed by f5
in the future i really like what black
is doing and white has to find something
and it's not there right now in the
position only seven minutes for furuja
18 minutes for fabiano a golden
opportunity for the american to strike
in this tournament
thank you christian going to the game
between lanier and ian at
first blush
jan's positions fine yeah but i'm not so
sure
yeah
i thought he sold every single uh
every single problem but books
is a very clever move by agreed by uh
lanier and it actually makes me wonder
if we were supposed to play rook c8
instead of rookie two not playing rookie
two of course is a very very difficult
proposition but maybe we were supposed
to take control over every single open
file and even at the cost of a pawn we
get these double rooks on the seventh
we're very happy we
because the key to rook c1 and now let's
say if you take on pizza we play i don't
know h4 i love h4 yeah some kind of move
like this followed by rc7
and you got to do something a little bit
awkward like this i mean takes a seven
followed by rook takes d5 this is yeah
you don't lose every single one of these
but you are
you'll you definitely lose some yeah
exactly you definitely lose some
something is
and by the way rooksy won rook e8 on the
board does threaten the backrack mate so
i'm assuming after you know i think once
again we played g3 or h4 i like it uh
the big question is whether
rookie one check will now the reason i'm
not happy about that g3
yeah i want to keep f2 protected as well
and yet
and jan very clearly needs to take rooks
off here so here over to you christian
breaking news it does seem like ali reza
has just simply blundered with his last
move rook to b5 now bishop to a6 is the
obvious move in the position what i
think he's looking for is some sort of
complication just give material and try
to create imbalances in the position the
problem is it's not enough rook to b3 uh
after queen to c5 you cannot move the
rook because queen takes f2 is coming in
the position this is just simply game
over for white so i'm expecting after
bishop to a6 something along the lines
of rook to f5 but what if i just simply
pick up that exchange it doesn't feel
like you have enough initiative and i
have so much control given by this
bishop b6 in combination with the queen
on this diagonal i'm going to put a lot
of pressure on your pawn also after
bishop to c5 open up the rook come to
beat with the rook put a lot of pressure
on f2 and it doesn't seem you have
enough resources on the kingside to
create any sort of imbalances and
attacks against my king i think ali reza
is just busted feels a little coffee
house but go ahead and continue
the position that you had on your screen
there after for example knight takes f1
takes f1 let's develop the last piece
yeah i was going to play knight on f3 to
h2 with the idea queen h5 and maybe you
know with the knight g4
knight g4 rookie 6 no i i meant queen h5
sorry uh instead of knight though yeah
just getting checkmated yourself but i
have enough resources you go knight g4 i
go rookie six i have enough pieces
around yeah even if let's say uh
disaster strikes and we have good knight
g4 rook takes g4 we're still too healthy
that's very
wow
okay uh it's not looking good if fabiano
plays the move bishop to a6 calls
alireza's bluff i think this is just
game over
well he's definitely eyeballing what
looks like a great opportunity there
i must say
and perhaps
he missed queen to c5 after rook to b3
queen to c5
perhaps this is what alireza missed
after rook to b3 and space 6 b3 queen to
c5
just because you are losing the exchange
right
yeah this uh
at this moment you mean yeah
i mean black is still much better if you
play queen f6 or somewhere but quincy
five just sort of ends the game because
yeah yeah you will just continue picking
up material for not very much exactly
the rook on f i could
is a5 ridiculous i apologize but is it
really
you should take
bishop
i was trying to save it on the board
guys yeah okay following his question
yeah
what do you got
let's see now
and here we go coffee house he's going
for it
all right so after bishop to f1
is there anything to be made about
knight takes g5
well but the issue is we're not
generating threats really that's the
problem yeah like it just i don't have
to take on g5 yeah it just doesn't does
generate threats yeah queen g4 queen g7
here or whatever yeah
yeah
it's not a sad thing it's it's a full
rook and there's not even a single check
you can threaten to be honest
i i i tease ben larson as being like the
best
example of coffee house players in the
west
and
ben ben rather light
my criticism of his play
did you have a
player let's say as you were coming up
you just looked at that guy and said you
know like you just think i was always i
think i was one you were one of the
coffee houses i think i was one in the
early in in the early stages of my
career very much so i think when i
relied on tactics yeah when i sort of
you know quote unquote burst onto the
scene in the in the mid 90s i was like i
had no idea about positional play
i was pretty good at dynamics and and
you know
generating generating mayhem and
navigating mayhem of all kinds but i i
absolutely like people just school be if
i got a boring position against the top
player i was just dead
people would outplay me so easily
how did you overcome that well you learn
i mean
my
tactical abilities were enough not to
drown immediately and then you learn
because you you people show you stuff
you
you you get shown it's so it's an
unpleasant way to learn because like
people like boris galvin would just kind
of you know
drag my nose nose across the board you
know it's an unpleasant learning i'm
thinking of a water buffalo with the
horse nose and
you know being pulled okay it's a but
but you do if you
if you don't become dispirited and if
you sort of hang around and you and you
survive for a year or two uh all of that
gets absorbed and also like for me i was
i mean by today's standards i was a very
old late bloomer like i became a
grandmaster at 18 you're supposed to
kind of retire right before that
but
well but uh you know i it still was
reasonably young in those years and um
you continue playing strong players you
continue being shown stuff which you
were kind of unaware of and hopefully
you you absorb some of it through uh in
those years you know post-mortem was
something that we always did yeah which
was great so i love you so much
i i learned so much from exactly like
you you lose an unpleasant game to to
let's say anatoly yeah and then you
analyze chess with him for three hours
after the game and there's so much so
much of it
drips down and right and gets absorbed
and
eventually you become better and you
know i became a competent i think
positional player eventually but
definitely not at the beginning so i'd
almost give you a contrasting uh
opponent vladimir kramnik i didn't think
of vladimir i thought of him as bursting
on the scenes as a positional player yes
i think
he was sort of born with the
understanding of where the pieces go
yeah
there are people like that who
even at a very very young age just don't
have a problem understanding where stuff
belongs on a very very instinctual level
and yeah i mean
if you were to cross your two cells i
think that would be a remarkable
opponent yeah i don't think i don't
think
rook f5 come on uh you say anything
did this does this tickle your heart uh
warm you i understand i understand why
he's doing that because the position
kind of looked looked hopeless and he is
at least introducing you know an element
of madness into it but should we take on
g5 now well bishop takes f1 knight takes
f1 is on the board rook to e8 is also on
the board
the engine's uh yeah top idea yeah and i
think the issue is if you take on g5
apart from the fact that hg is probably
playable you can also just go rookie
five and trade
queen h5 now
this this worries me a little bit
because i i can't immediately say how
we're protecting stuff i i yeah i would
rather go rookie five instead i think
but then like the seven knight h6
this is why
maybe the other this is uh now this is
suddenly very playable yeah so what if
you take on g5 so g5 hg queen h5 and now
queen b3
queen e3 queen b3 defending the pawn on
f zone how do you mate me and if you
don't then rook to e5 might be coming
soon
clear yeah
i mean that's that
it's going to be an uncomfortable
decision for fabian but i think it's
findable yeah queen h6 i guess rookie 6
is what we're planning to do
yeah because yeah once again we're going
to shed some pawns there that's okay g5
rogue g6 but we still haven't take a few
i go king of faith queen f7 is coming
back
yeah this will be winning a king of fate
and then eventually the queen will
introduce yeah the problem is you cannot
really involve your knight into the
attack right or
yeah
these guys are staying at home
they're not uh contributing and it's
just queen versus the rest
um
also ali reza has only four minutes
right now yeah make that decision i
think you close your eyes i can go like
this and take one yeah because if you if
you don't you you'll know you know this
is not going well for you like how do
you defend the pawn on d4 any any uh
any reasons to throw in the movie e5
okay let's take that not that i'm i'm
enthusiastic
i just want to be very clear about this
and non-ig5 yeah i understand your point
but i i don't know if that improves
anything like that
hg clean h5 queen c4 or queen b3 once
again you know yeah just feels very
similar yeah feels very similar
only i'm missing my e4 pawn
um so you can take on g5 and king f8
queen h8 and then take on e5 but
is that enough i
think so right yeah maybe
but but another issue with the 45 is
that uh black gets the tempo to do
something else if we go all the way back
to just the five move uh move 21
i'm very tempted to find a good passing
like rookie six for nc five rook is six
just after e5 yeah just to really
discourage you from all of that knight
takes g5 shenanigan ray
that's probably yes not award yeah
chicanery
no i said shenanigans yeah i know but i
think uh
canery might
might suffice in this case yeah uh yeah
i love your rookie six by the way i
think that's just super solid
which is why which is why um i mean was
there something to be said for this
other yeah i think so yeah he took it he
took it okay and fabi said okay nobody
believes you
and now we did sequence is there a
difference between c4 and queen b3
you were sort of very pointedly choosing
the b3 square here no
queen c4 is fine as well
is bishop takes f2 i was about to say is
bishop takes f2 an issue it's the best
move but just go queen b3 defend that
pawn
yeah bishop takes f2 can be played of
course
rook five rookie five you're never
generating another threat in this game
no no no no no and the fact that the
knight can't leave because there's a
background check is also
uh very disconcerting uh by the way
bishop f2 really looks good queen b3
that is a rook i mean after all rook is
a rook
so fabiano has options right now to
close the game he has options he also
has 10 more minutes on his clock so he
should be able to forward this one and
again uh fabi at this exact moment uh
three out of six possible points sitting
at fifty percent a win right uh he's on
minus one but uh he's out of eight yeah
three out of eight yeah
right
yeah and uh yeah if you if you have to
play something like king h2 here you're
you kind of know this is only going to
get worse
for sure
i know
so what do we do if if white continues
like throwing uh throwing things into
the fire like king h2 specifically
bishop takes
king
um
because
you know it feels like you still have to
play some some quiet move here of some
sort and i don't particularly like right
well just the fact that we've now earned
this
i mean i'm i'm even oh yeah
you know i can do with this kind of
business mm-hmm yeah this is yes sir
actually yeah this is the solution here
ouch ouch ouch ouch so bishop f2 almost
requires rook f2 and then
then your move queen g7 peter really
hurt my feelings but that is just very
very clearly
end of end of the road here for white
because we have no attack down a bunch
of material right
exactly
in the meantime we have some end games
please uh on other boards why does a
pawn up in three games out of five today
in an end game and i think white
probably is
unlikely the way king h2 won the ball
any of them uh
uh white
being a pawn up isn't all it's cracked
up to be uh lanier
did get an extra pawn
against
uh nepo h7h5 last move by black uh and
you said this should be quite
comfortable this should be
why peter why
just help our view i mean your
assessment was uh
lickety-split i mean the rook on a2 is
exactly where it's supposed to be we uh
are
almost here
we are almost ready to start some
counter play on the king's side if white
continues passing the king is cut off on
the back rank i think the best chance to
do anything at all here would be to play
rook a5 or rook g7 whatever you choose
give up the a pawn win the g pawn play
king e2 king e3 but
i mean famously wise occasionally loses
this black i mean the weaker side
occasionally loses these types of end
games right we saw for instance magnus
carlsen loses a position like this
against juan howe in one of the
stavanger tournaments so
one of the years right but
it's
i think generally speaking a reasonably
comfortable draw if you if you keep your
wits about you okay
and the other
two games that you were about to say
that's not this one this one actually is
equal pawns uh but uh shaq is still a
pawn up against hikaru but hikaru's
improved his position dramatically i
think hikaru will will save the game now
very very comfortable oops i'm on the
wrong
game there
um no
it moves on me
where are where is there it is sorry
yeah i think i think this is a market
improvement for black now the whoa
g3 is going to be a target and it's this
is where we were struggled
we were very excited about the move rook
d7
and shaq played knight d6 he's got his
extra pawn but he always had that yeah
and
the black pieces are just so much more
active and the the structure on the king
side will provide counter play it's not
a like you can't claim this is always
good
but uh it's it's obviously a much much
better situation than we saw what he was
facing yeah early in the game also from
shaq being six or seven minutes up on
the clock right now he's down three
minutes
only five minutes for him to convert
this on not an easy task yeah and uh mvl
is actually a pawn up against against
sam
in another game
today
where is he
just there number nine yeah and then we
need to scroll up a little bit because
we
yeah scroll the board
right it gets repositioned
and by the way it seems like feroza
versus uh fabiano went specifically into
that variation that we're looking at
king to h2 queen to g7
and ferruja with only 12 seconds on the
clock
resignation is
on the cards there yeah for sure
he's gone 93 and the other
you can probably take on a five and play
queen uh f6 or even h7 probably is
winning to be honest also you can go
rook beat right now there is absolutely
no need for you to even calculate yeah
it's concrete
yeah that's nice
yeah
boy i think ali
raza really had resignation ready there
yeah he didn't hesitate for a moment
once queen h
yeah
once queen eight um wow i mean up to
this exact moment uh farouza was a
tournament leader looking really good
and my gosh uh
one bad move out of the opening and he
just never recovered really does seem
like one
strange misstep very very early in the
game and there was no way back
yeah for those of you joining as late
right here the move d3 d4 was mis-timed
badly mistimed
many games
in the theory books with bishop takes
and now d5
and uh but the way it happened
with d3d4 mistake knight takes pawn
takes takes and the big difference is
black is not obliged yeah black is not
obliged to play with the xc6 yes
precisely so it's obviously a tremendous
difference and uh
fabi went on to convert this quite
comfortably well done fabi uh jan
yes that's the ending that you felt if
he keeps his wits yeah that that that's
what it's about
uh levon uh levon is actually sort of
pushing but you get the feeling it
shouldn't be enough
um because of just how few few pawns are
left on the king's side and eventually
some counterplay will
who's pushing in that one
nobody probably
nobody's pushing
probably nobody huh uh and the one
that's pushing his mvo most likely and
christian what's your take on the game
between shakriar and hikaru both players
looking for a result in this one
absolutely but it does seem like this
one is going to go down
towards a drop because you just have too
many weaknesses on the king side as
white i'm going to take on g3 follow it
up with route to g8 it's going to be
very awkward for you to defend those
weaknesses i think icarl will be able to
equalize this one he's not anywhere
close to being better with black pieces
but he definitely improved his case in
the last few moves
cool yeah in particular in particular
because of the trend yeah i mean because
he must know he was in trouble early on
right right i do feel like we do have
this type of positions with one pawn uh
up for one of the sides
the bigger advantage is the one between
mvl and chatland and maybe we can take a
look at that one okay
yeah that does seem like the one where
uh
white winning is not unthinkable even
though bishops have the same color
even though you still feel that the the
very very active rook on h2 and the fact
that creating a passer on the queen side
is going to be quite problematic because
of how well the bishop 26 controls
everything
bad bishops control uh protect good
pawns
you could also maybe try to
make some kind of a semi force draw here
with rook h3 but i would prefer just not
to even try to calculate anything
intimidating that you want to play
bishop takes g4 and then the idea
uh to continue
yeah the moment the moment the the king
departs from the best square on the
board which clearly easily three right
now we just start giving checks exactly
and if it has to by the way three it's
going to be completely misplaced on g3
not really in particular by the way i
think i'm blundering there i had to go
king to e2 keeping the bishop protected
yeah he's got rook h3 actually so he is
trying to uh make the draw sort of by
force you can play with calisthenics yes
rook h2 back
and yeah this is the issue for mvl like
counterplay maybe there is none
currently but how are you making any
progress exactly so why did i start with
bishop e2 not a big fan of the rook
maybe i could reposition the rook from
e3 to a better square and then perhaps
place you three c4 and ask sam if you if
you are so confident of holding that
rope ending exactly which
by the way uh looks a little bit like
the linear
versus um and maybe you should go from
b5 right yeah b5 c5 as well is an option
here and there you go yeah he goes b66
which is yeah
was our first port of call there
absolutely well but our first protocol
love it
rook v6 rook c6
and uh we're getting a lesson in rook
endings huh christian yeah it does seem
like yeah and you don't have a way to uh
approach it with the king king to f6 is
going to be bent by uh c4 and you cannot
take on c4 because of d5 that's the
problem that's a mind square f6 for the
black king if you want to go passive
with king to f8 that just doesn't feel
right no it's it's not much fun yeah it
feels like you know you've you've
generated about as much activity as you
could
and you're still going to have to play
some kind of a waiting game he goes
ruxin
luxury six will be the reply and we'll
see actually uh linear's end game
against uh
jan has become much sharper than i
expected because okay
somewhat shockingly uh jan has a an
outside passer on h4 like what
dwight has to when we left it it was
kind of three if versus four and it was
a past deep one
for the plan of creating very very
concrete counter play here with okay one
rook h1 kind of asking the question how
how happy are you about
uh giving up
the pawn on h4 and linear went for this
one and now king e2 um and uh
e2 h3
yeah this should still be a draw i guess
the point here is that if you play d6 uh
he's gone rook d3 interesting um
finish your thought h2 h2 rook h3 and
here ah the simplest is i guess just to
play king of seven but the the one i
found was rookie one here perhaps
okay rook h206 which appears to be
winning that pawn for me and then i hold
quite comfortably a little bit too far
yeah
so he has and now he has the same now he
has the same option if he wants it but
he is i think he's planning h2h3
we can't actually play okay one rook a5
here if we wanted to i don't think
there's anything wrong with that
that's easiest right yeah i think that's
the easiest yeah but with the pawn on f2
your winning chances really are r zero
zero aren't really that stellar by the
way a draw looks uh to have been
declared between lavon and jeffrey no
not an experiment no surprises not
unexpected jeffrey not looking like a
wild card player but looking perfectly
at home
uh between all of these stars of the
chess world
yeah also really not a surprise we've
known we've known him as a very very
solid player for quite some time uh jan
cho's king of six instead of rook a1
which is still fine with h5
first of all we can go back with uh with
king g6 but king e7 is also going to be
completely okay
king six
yeah the issue i mean there's just no
threat
uh because i'm gonna do this uh
a different way i'm just going to
basically whenever you go king on the
third rank i'm going to go route to d1
yeah rook g1 rook takes d5 and we are
you know we have
very comfortable drawing territory
lots and lots of tempi and reserve yeah
king of the there's really nothing else
anyway so he goes for it but yeah rudy
wonder
d5 there's
really not very much to play for here
i think there was only one 2600 level
player that actually lost the affiliate
or position
uh that's from your country from romania
yeah
the way i got
uh president and he actually bought his
rating from like 1800 to 2600. and then
he lost affiliate
yeah well
but uh losing the philadelphia position
well
it could cost you a lot yeah and the
players are going to make a quick draw
here
nice okay that's how you draw the total
door position so we have only two games
running uh one is mvl versus uh sam and
the the shock
trying to push with an extra pawn
against hikaru those are the only two
and we do see peace
on the board uh one of the
one of the nice things from shaq's point
of view i mean is uh there are a lot of
ways uh for him to still improve his
game i want to put it like that i mean
he's enjoying his extra pawn he can play
for king b2 he can put his work on
e3 but
the problem is i'm not really
always going to getting
there's always going to be enough so
what if i try to uh solve this through
tactical methods
i was wondering
uh how h4 let's go a4
a3 a4 a4 right now wow yay thank you you
take that one yeah then i go kingy cell
threatening to take one oh oh you did
take on e5 right away yeah you've got
king e7
okay
um
that's not gonna be yeah i think i was
looking at something like this but i
think it's very difficult to force
yourself to play
uh
such an obvious continuation in a
practical game when you don't really
know how well it works right even though
i think it's very understandable why it
does work because the white pieces
suddenly are so discoordinated that
it's difficult to even difficult to even
name a move right
exactly
so now he played uh
he
didn't he played your suggestion
i wanted to go knight to three he takes
a3 now
huh what a nasty and then we play for a
win yeah on knight c6 maybe we don't
play for a while what a nasty now bishop
c1 maybe yeah bishop c1
bishop d22
yeah that is uh that is apparently white
actually needs to start actively looking
for a
uh that is that is very funny um
oh we don't have rookie five though
knight six for bishop c1 and rookie five
bishop hold on what was that what was
that position that we were there yeah
three's on the board yeah yeah he played
rookie three and now three knight c6
bishop c1 and we don't go to e1 we go to
e5 are we
very nice
and white probably still maintains some
advantage even though i suspect it's a
draw after knight c6 anyway
okay but bishops of opposites colors
with the extra pawn
don't you understand young man in such
positions i never lose
an extra pawn up in ambition very very
true yeah i think
i think he does want to take on a3 he
wants to take on a3 that that was what
uh stahlberg had told uh
i don't know
bishop
knight c6 i guess just rook d6 now
because 96 remains remains a playable
move in this position i mean why are we
allowing this i'm getting confused
knight c6
looks attractive yeah it remains a
playable move and especially because i'm
also forking this pawn on a5 yeah
exactly like rook d6 we could i will
take on a5 i think right now knight c6
might win material and yeah yeah i think
maybe that's what he's calculated knight
c6 he played rook to d3 he played rogue
d3 and now i would like to play rook i
know i can't because there's a fork on
d7 i was going to suggest rook h8h2 but
that blunder is a full piece in one move
so that's probably
not good yeah he'll advise yeah he's
he's actually reached for the rook yeah
okay obviously not the player yeah
rook d6 kind of a solid solid setup with
everything protected if white could
somehow push b3 before what would become
better but it's currently very very
difficult to organize so g4 probably
doesn't yield yeah g4 just fg and king
of five and like i think solves all of
his problems immediately was
was the uh move knight c6 that easy uh
christian at one point instead of rook
d3 uh we we we've kind of been looking
at the 96 rook d6 yeah 596 is what i
mean and knight takes a5 launch e6
knight takes a5 knight to c6 or bishop
takes a3 evil
well bishop takes a3 as a swap and it's
an option the knight c6 and i don't have
a good answer for knight c6 no knight to
c6 you can take take take
i take on a5 and
d5 but yeah we can take on b3 and go
after the king side yeah it's just a
drawing okay this is the position
currently we have on the board hikaru
falling down to his last 40 seconds 30
seconds right
rook d1 on the board
nice to play changing the
the
situation on the board but now look to
h1 right you start ah having to think
about rook h7 or f7 checkmating id yeah
well knight takes a three though and
rogue bishop d4 is also made that's
amazing
who gets to make whom first
that is also made so you but knight
takes a3 i go bishop d3 isn't that nice
okay so
let's pursue the line
rook h1 knight a3 bishop which one is
also
we should no no
i can't pronounce words anymore but yeah
okay e2 bishop e2 by shaq wait a minute
97 97 is back back to being a threat can
we take on a3 with the bishop though
so 19 73 i guess four king the king as
well as the bishop so you wanted to say
bishop takes a three i'm i'm wondering
if this is playable but
it's certainly legal yeah bishop d3
knight e3 knight d3 and then bishop c5
seems to be playable
absolutely it seems like but then look
h1 yeah but then then then rook h1 h7
how is that
uh
pulling pulling all the stops yeah but
now
looks great
before we get to trade stuff let's see
what we make
to add well
uh
is a draw if we want to avoid an
immediate drawing i guess we take on g6
and then go knight c4 and bishop c7 c7
but at least the knights don't come off
the board immediately so we played it on
king b2 exactly
yeah and you're dreaming that 20 against
17 by the way
not the hardest position to play in the
world but still
now now 15 against 17 kg7 how did how
did the engine like them apples uh
christian was king g7 the right move
there um not not the best by any means
he will have to defend this end game
that we're actually going into right now
c4 you can't really give up on a5 i
think bishop c7 looks logical what
you're looking for right now is
straightforward ways to simplify the
position and you don't have them right
yeah once you play once you put the
bishop on c7 your connection between
your bishop and your knight has been
broken and white can play yeah i don't i
think looks like he's looking at bishop
d1 but i like king b2 i don't see any
reason not to not to bring the king in
king b2 knight g4 bishop g suddenly this
is a game
you know bishop d3 or bishop yeah bishop
d1 maybe is smarter just to keep keep an
eye for e5 at some point yeah i think
hikar will play knight c6 and start
pushing for e65 yeah which is why bishop
g3 i guess was chosen yeah still 96
though i i find that so strange when a
top player like uh shakriar plays bishop
to d1
holds holds his hand on the bishop and
then puts it on d3 it's like dude
you hadn't determined where to make your
move uh
do you find that off-putting when your
opponents do it or not particularly no
it doesn't bother you i bothered now no
okay
i was much more bothered when i did when
i did that myself against shah last year
and lost on time that was that didn't
bother me
what have you done peter well i wanted
to play i think king g2f3 as a reply to
a check and then i realized that loses
the full rook tonight if 95 check knight
takes d7 and i started laughing
put the king back on g2 because i didn't
release it and just sort of sat there
kind of giggling for the entirety of my
remake
instead of making any kind of a legal
move which would have been an immediate
draw yikes
now the knight is coming to d6
yeah probably
i think icarus still doesn't lose this
but yeah it probably became
more complicated than it needed to be
knight d6 as you recommended christian
on the board let's see that's going to
be an immediate draw you have to
redirect the knight
keep the knight
you know knight f7 played by i think
icaru is now realized but he's going e5
e65 is going to be a useful thing to do
yeah i think i think shock probably
replies to this by playing like knight
c6 e5 king e3
allowing efgf but keeping at least in
your right
exactly some bits of some bits of his
structure under control yeah i think you
you probably still should play five
something like e5 king e3 we take on f4
we go knight h896 probably is a draw or
knight g8 96 something like that
and by the way mvl seems to be uh
winning his end game why is he 65 needed
i'm kind of surprised well
first of all after king to d6 it does
seem like he's already lost
after he takes d5 because you don't have
a way to defend both pawns if you take
on d5 i'm going to go rook to a a5
followed by rook to a6 and rook to g6
you're just simply too far away with
your king you cannot defend both pawns
you're going to have to be in a passive
position if i get the rook to e5 imagine
a rook a black rook on g8 you don't want
to see that because i'm simply going to
go king to e3 followed by f4 it's a
technical win right now for white and if
he wins this one he's going to be in
seoul first position and vl that is leap
frogging five other players it's
incredible impressive and by the way
king d3 on the board yeah this is now
cruising easily to victory this looks
like uh
almost you can chalk it up as a that
seems reasonably straightforward the
best thing you can hope for is to take
on f3 but then i take on d4 rook a6
route g6
it's not looking good yeah rucker you
can even play king e4 here if you want
to be uh fancy about these things but i
don't think you need to
i don't know that's
yeah no i don't think you need it either
but it it does look kind of attractive
actually fancy play
yeah and hikaru play d5 he's going to
draw that game
well this would be again as we're as the
grand chess tour winds down the season
of the grand chess tour and with mvl so
close
to wesley so
a big result in this game really sets up
the sinkville cup for a fantastic finish
absolutely yeah yeah
how do you win this position by the way
because of d4 huh king e4 is the best
movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you have to play king you can e4 g3
i guess we give a check from a6 and
after king d7 maybe we're in time to
actually play okay tour guitar that's
what i was trying to figure out
depending on where you put the king you
start thinking also about but even even
here
even here let's say king d6 rocket uh
rookie launcher
and king of five rookie three i thought
no king f5 rookie five over five five
yeah that's a problem rookie in d4 we
have king g4
oh but that that pawn end game is a draw
why is why are we winning here
sorry which one
king d4 rookie five
i think this king can keep king and pawn
ending as a draw king e4 d3 on the board
yeah all of this all of this is played
so yeah sam is definitely not hopeless
here this is this is a tricky position
to play on very very low time and uh mvl
has more time than uh than sam but not a
lot of time for for an end game such as
this yeah obviously we never play king
c5 to get cut off along
uh along those those files i think
that's very very unnatural
even though we do get to to win some
material by doing that king d7 we're
expecting rook eight yeah okay so and
now we go king is king
and he's reaching for his king and
looking at his clock uh what are we
talking about 20 seconds for sam
yeah 25 seconds against two minutes yeah
rugby two will be played and you
this is a drawer right now
so we saved it
was it this one after rook b2 was that
you just needed you just to be able to
attack the pawn on g5 immediately g2 is
actually sort of the worst square on the
board because we have a group b5 check
or rook h5 we actually placed our rook
on the horrible horrible square gotcha
yeah and this is why i was confused
because your your hand makes the move
you do for you so so to speak right but
it's rook h2
uh intending to
i think it might be a took swung out
honestly exactly i think it might just
be impossible to make a good move here
king c5 i think now we take on d3
uh runnier two and two and rook h5 yeah
and yeah sam knows sam knows that this
pawn ending is a draw and as i was
mentioning rook d3 we just take on d5 we
take on d3 we go we maintain the
opposition it's
he's just going for it he knows
should this game end in a draw however
and that is to say mbl not taking uh
seoul first there will be a huge a huge
up but
at the top there with five people tied
for first on plus one half the field
half the field so one save
[Laughter]
so
when we start to talk about tiebreakers
e2 might get problematic if not lost
yeah
you might still be okay but you don't
want to you don't want to mess around
with those yeah
can you do kingdom 6. yeah just just
maintain the distant opposition here
yeah
is actually playing for a win but
oh my goodness
well i mean
he's not going to win but he is sort of
he is now the side the side playing for
a win yeah i see
he has his
and a draw has been agreed uh between uh
sam
sam has
he saved a number of positions i wanted
absolutely
again that game with uh
perugia should he have won that game
that would have uh been quite the
stunner
and we're going to get a queen yeah
that's no he would have known
which is very stylish yeah i like i like
the knight there yeah um i have under
promoted to at night maybe bishop yeah i
famously lost a very very important
world cup game to vladimir malhot where
the final move was g2 takes the
one-night check ouch which was
potentially maybe the only winning move
in that position it wasn't very
difficult but it was potentially the
only winning move in the position
wow
once again an eventful round not too
much blood being so far i think the
flabby game
was the decider sorry i wanted to say i
think we are on two decisive games out
of ten so far which is very very low for
this tournament but the games no no
shortage of excitement just no decisive
games full of content christian
absolutely no absolutely and what an
important victory for fabiano because it
felt after day one and even the first
game from day two that he was just not
himself but such an important and
dominant victory with the black pieces
against virujah it does seem like
whenever he plays furuja he plays like
himself even in the candidates with the
black pieces he won as well i remember
the game from the grand swiss
against firuja with the white pieces
dominated alireza in that one as well it
does seem like ali reza is struggling
whenever he plays against fabiano and he
took
a full control in this game
we always talk about
customers uh peter that sometimes you
just have a a good customer even though
mathematically speaking by the elo you
shouldn't be having such an outside yeah
there are there's such such much
absolutely yeah throughout player way
player b who always loses to player c
who always beats players and there is a
so far appears to
somewhat struggle against let's say
magnus and fabiano but if like if your
biggest problem in chess is
you know you can you can recover over
time exactly it's an understandable one
exactly well uh that it was around uh
five we'll be back shortly for the sixth
and final round
but we may
uh have a another interview uh
possibly possibly
we'll we'll get the standings up for
first screen for now makes sense
the interviews will probably follow the
last round of the day but for now let's
uh let's bring up that uh five choir
very top
and that would be uh players who are
plus
plus one here in in
old parliament
in old parliament with the
no no standings for us just just a break
uh
just a break just
yeah uh everybody's tight for first
place half the field this time enjoy
enjoy a short break and we'll be back
for the last round of the day today
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and here we are with our last round of
the day but before that the standings
and as we promised you half the field is
tied for first
with alireza losing that game to fabiano
the only decisive game around five and a
bunch of draws
and the chasing pack caught up yeah so
as you can see alireza yan mbl linear
dominguez and jeffrey shong are all in
plus one a couple of people are in 150
fabi and sam
uh levon and picaro are uh on minus one
and shakir continues
uh trading the field there on two points
out of ten absolutely as
we get ready for round six anastasia
actually caught up with
round five winner fabiana let's take a
listen
[Music]
adriana you just won the game against
the leader of the tournament
how important this victory is for you
yeah it's very good of course um i mean
it's still the start of the tournament
but it was a gift uh this is
a rare week week moment for our ali reza
i mean he out of the opening things just
went very badly
um
i guess he was experimenting a bit with
a playable line but
um d4 immediately is not the way to play
it
and then things i don't know if he
overlooked c3 but soon he was down upon
for no compensation
i think i even had uh
let's say the pun and i had the
compensation because i also had a good
good position on top of that
and then he went for an exchange
sacrifice which was very desperate
but i understand that he was um
hoping that at least my king is weak and
he can start an attack
but i i think this was quite accurate
how i played it with uh bishop takes f2
especially
and this one was really nice actually
did you count everything in movie yeah
yeah it's uh it's i don't know if it's
necessary but i didn't see anything else
which was clear because rookie seven
looks like a huge mess to me and bishop
takes up two is very forcing
if he takes it then his king gets uh
into the attack or if he takes with the
rook then his attack uh finishes on the
king's side and he's left somebody down
in exchange in a few pawns and the
problem with this king on the h file is
that even though he wins my queen uh he
starts to get mated because his king is
is stuck there
and my works will come to the h5 file
very quickly so after that it was it was
very easy yeah you won the game the
first game in this tournament the how
was the yesterday it felt that you
couldn't still find your way
yeah yesterday i played quite poorly um
i had chances for sure
um i think in the first round against
sam although i was also close to losing
or maybe just losing i also had good
chances to win
um
second game was unfortunate jeffrey came
super well prepared and
uh still i had some chances to draw the
game at the end a total miracle
and and then in the last game against
jan i also had some chances to win
but overall my play wasn't good so i
i can't even be upset that it was only
minus one because i think it could have
been worse with how i played yeah but
now okay finally when you are
in the 50 at the moment so with which
results you will be happy in this
tournament
i i don't know i mean a plus four would
be good um i think i would be happy with
the plus score because then that puts me
in at least
i think anyone who has a plus core has a
good chance to fight for
for the top places in the blitz um
because that's where the majority of the
ups and downs are usually and you see a
lot of leaders shifting um
but usually the players who score well
in the rapid are
you know usually finished among the top
yeah so here we are in the santos chess
club on the background you can see the
chess boards and everything so how does
it feel to play home
it's it's good i was traveling a huge
amount um
the olympiad last the candidates and
and all sorts of tournaments in between
before that
so it's good to be back and the last
tournament i played here i had a big
success uh so
hopefully i can continue yeah we wish
you all the best of luck again in the
next rounds thank you
site where the the the march in 1886 was
played but here here are pairings for
our last round of the day uh
yanipanische is white against cicara
nakamura uh shanklin mamizarov a very
interesting game between jeffree strong
who continues to impress and mvl both
will be now both tied for first uh five
years wide against the one and another
game between two people tied for first
uh lanier dominguez is white against
alireza furuja nice to
two key match-ups as the games for this
our sixth and final round of uh day two
are now underway absolutely and i i do
want to uh we were not in the shot and
we didn't need to be in the show but i
will i want to
uh kind of
convey my uh you know surprise pikachu
face about the plus four statement by
hikaru because uh
there are four there are four rounds
left he's on fifty percent
so he says i will be satisfied with plus
four
uh that's score i thought i'd be
satisfied with the plus score yes ah
okay i that that's just because plus
four yeah yeah i'd be satisfied with
plus four though yeah when you're only
getting fifty percent me too
it's not great but at least i know now
that i'm going deaf so exactly
um we do have uh a grunfeld yeah this is
a very reasonable line this is a very
very fashionable line it's supposed to
be a draw
uh but white generally like i don't
think white has lost a single one of
these games but white wins like one in
three one in four of these
this is just what you're doing kind of
thing yeah this has become huge the
hugely topical and recent uh
i think the first one i've seen there
may have been ones earlier but there was
a game that
i want to say prague one in the uh riga
grand swiss in 2021 against ajibon yeah
that there there it was on our screen
there
uh ajiba was fine for a very very long
time in that game and then made one
mistake and everything everything was
over the point here is that
in order not to give any material back
you're supposed to take on e5
and then white maintains this very very
annoying pressure you play you take take
you play queen a5 for instance here you
uh
you maintain this kind of a setting
where
you're
but you have to give up the bishop on g7
exactly it's not that horrible because
you often will be able to play f7 f6 and
sort of nullify that that
pressure against long diagonal at least
to some extent
but it's it's also immediately obvious
that white will have tremendous
compensation for a long time and uh why
why the move rook f1 b1 uh peter i mean
you're kind of putting the rook on one
and i think i think the previous games
all went through kb1 if i remember
correctly or at least the ones that i
was talking about they all went through
kp1 it's some kind of a new quirk i
don't exactly know how this changes the
the outcomes to be honest we will see uh
clearly uh jeffrey has opinions on this
jeffrey is very very well prepared as we
keep on mentioning and exactly
all right uh
christian uh jump right in on this
question about the rooks rook a1 to b1
rook f1 to b1 yeah that's a very good
question
nuances on that one my guess is that
with the rook with this rook on b1 he
has the option of going bishop to f4 but
then again why didn't he have the option
with this other rook potentially because
after bishop to e6 this pawn on a2 is
going to be protected but we just have
to wait and see what jeffrey comes up
with he definitely is very much aware of
the nuances in the position fabiano is
playing a very interesting game as well
against levon check this out so they got
into this very uh theoretical battle
knight takes c3 bishop to b7 and oh my
goodness
and h4 was fabiano's move and he knew
that he
has 26 minutes at this point and 24
seconds queen to e7 queen to c2 he is
still within his preparation what i
think he wants to do is long castle
h5 h6 and try to kill black on the
king's side
it's going to be a very very intriguing
game because black is not going to stay
put they're going to try to open up the
position on the queen side as well or in
the center via d5 and try to get some
counter play this is going to be a very
interesting one as well yeah that
definitely looks like an exciting game
in progress there uh levon just playing
knight b87 as we speak which i think
makes perfect sense uh trying to bring
that knight over to f6 to shore up uh
our defenses on the king side a little
bit even though
if i'd ever manages to let's say castle
queen side and then go g4 g5 so let's go
castle yeah castle we go knight f6 i
assume i think this is the plan
and apart from protecting the h7 pawn
from bishop d3 threats it also supports
our potential d65 count to play i
understand why vale1 is playing it like
this and pushing for g2 g4 is not that
simple because the pawn f3 is hanging so
perhaps you have to spend the temp on
something like bish pizzu which is not
the most attractive or the most
threatening move in the world so black
probably has ways of treating it
with
the disrespect it deserves
with the disrespect it deserves i like
that
nice
it feels feels
christian uh the approach that bobby has
taken with h2h4 is this known
absolutely a lot of fresh stuff let's
see how new it is because they were both
blitzing out uh their moves so if i
remember correctly
the game from round two i think it was
between fabiano and nepal went something
very similar and after bishop to d2 i
think nepo started with d5 instead of c5
now this is we got yeah there is
actually uh quite a few games
dx e6 was the novel move f3 previously
was played in quite a few uh top-level
games san diego seems to be a proponent
of this type of situation but of course
after take take black has the extra
option of potentially uh actually taking
on d5 probably is not good after queen
takes d5
f takes e6 uh dtx excuse me is a new
wrinkle and then we have this one and no
transpositions up to this point so this
is fresh theory and both of them seem to
be aware of uh the ideas in the position
all right thank you for that uh where
would you like to take us i think we
should kind of mention all the other
games
in the round uh the quietest one and the
one we probably should come to the last
is the the game between shankland uh and
mamidarov but we have a very sharp uh
cairo that uh
yasa just brought up in the game between
uh linear and uh
alireza alireza going for this uh
setup in the karakan with the
uh kind of a slow development 97 97
bishop h7 not pushing c65 which is the
way to try to equalize on the spot right
which is i think very often uh this is
something that people do uh to play for
a win with black because the resulting
positions
the engine dislikes very often quite
significantly
for black but
they're very difficult to play with for
both sides very often uh no trades
happen for quite some time so you have
really weird positions with 32 pieces on
the board and some kind of a maneuvering
quite a long while too many maneuvering
fight ensues right it's very difficult
to navigate properly and i've done this
myself with black and must win games
it's risky as i said you are not
guaranteed to equalize by any means but
it's definitely something that people do
specifically to get a game uh linear i
think understands these positions as
honestly is the case with most positions
quite well but uh going to be a very
interesting one there is also uh a very
sharp catalan between yanipam nishin
hikaru nakamura with with
126.42 currently this is a very very
topical line of
of the catalan we don't need to go
through the whole sphere i will mention
though that in the very recently
concluded uh series of rapid tournaments
on chess.com which gun eventually won in
the final against michelin draken
along the way
he bit hikaru in a catalan
so they've been kind of discussing this
opening recently
online enough yeah and uh in in that
tournament fikaro chose a different line
which was very very critical but it
turned out that jan knew what was going
on there a little bit better than hikaru
did and uh it ended up with a white
victory and uh they're discussing this
now give us your assessment of what's
going on in the position and why the
inclusion of h4 when it's quite clear
that white's
pining for the move e4 i think uh
i i mean the correct answer i know the
correct answer and the correct answer is
because the computer tells you to play
it
that's the correct answer that's the way
it works today yes
but why does the computer play tell you
i'm assuming it's the most useful
waiting move queen i want to have notes
among other things so i would i would
please looking through the variations
and i think i understand what the
computer wants to do in this position
knight to b6 queen to a1 if you do go
queen to c2 you run into all sorts of
queen to d7 and then f5 maybe bishop to
e4 later on in the game queen to a1 now
imagine where are you going to put the
bishop on c1 after for example the move
such as bishop to e4 if you do go bishop
to f4 then i have the move knight to d5
hitting the bishop defending the pawn on
c7 as well and gaining a tempo but
white has this extra option of bishop to
g5 and this is my guess this is why he
played the move h4 this is why we're
going to see in position of course if we
play the move f6 this is a problem you
never play f6 you're not supposed to
play f6 in this type of situations the
pawn on e6 is going to frankly any type
of situation in any situations we just
ask us
exactly
so this is what i think um
jan right now has in store for hikaru
it's going to be very interesting to see
how hikaru is going to react to that
move bishop to g5 well there's no queen
a1 it just feels like alpha zero
territory here like what is that come on
peter i mean you know
the the old guys would just be like
turning over in their graves right
trying to understand chess has become in
particular in topical lines like this
one undoubtedly is it just chess has
become extremely concrete
so
once again quincy two would of course be
much much more natural but it does allow
black to gain something with my before
perhaps right uh and
the engine just suggests that queen a1
is stronger and once again i think you
know compared to that game that i
brought up earlier the one that they
played online
that was a much sharper line this is a
line where i think you have much more
leeway to be slightly inaccurate right
out of the opening i think for hikaru
this is much less
risky than uh than that game
they played a bit earlier but
you're still uh
he's sitting there against somebody who
is once again on 26 minutes by move 16
right
even if you understand that you're not
running as many risks as perhaps you
would in some other lines of the catalan
you're still not enjoying yourself very
much because once again
you got out prepared
there's definitely something in this
position which seems attractive for jan
to try this is exactly why not queen to
c2 and queen to a1 was the better move
and the move recommended by the engines
of course with a queen on c2 after queen
to d7 you don't have to move knight to
c3
back because i can just simply take on
f3 follow it up with knight takes d4
that comes with tempo and i have enough
time to take on f3 with the check
this is a key difference in the position
now
and if we do it off the queen to seven
knight c3 here sometimes like king g2 is
a problem exactly yes and the line
continues black is not much worse or
losing or anything of that nature but
black needs to find some really precise
moves to stay in the game and this is
what nebo is trying to get this is very
reminiscent of that game alireza played
against magnus but there were like yes
bits of it are sort of exactly the same
but obviously the situation on the queen
side here is quite different to
uh to what they had there and uh yeah
and we do have knight c3 on the board
he's on the board right
yeah and hikaru is uh
he's not happy yeah he is concentrating
really hard because he he understands
that
probably the solution exists uh but
by you know most likely he will have to
come up with it over the board whereas
his opponent just knows and this is
never comfortable right exactly
how deep is nepo's prep here after uh
this move king g2 honestly doesn't look
that horrible to to my eyes because i
think i can go bishop f6 but i guess
bishop v6 maybe they play knight d4
because if i play three here
i think that is fine knight b3 rook g7
knight a1 roxy said when i go i come
back to b3
that doesn't look remotely worrying to
my eyes because the big t1 got stuck it
sure did by the way
oops yeah yeah but i think bishop 6
probably the idea is to play knight e4
and this is another position in which uh
that fact that we have bishop g5
somewhere uh might become very relevant
and even bishop g5 immediately uh also
because i i was worried about that
knight b3 uh and the bishop being stuck
but you're right knight e4
um
it's
i'm i'm trying to assess a p sacrifice
something like c5 e3 e5 which is
ridiculous of course but trying to get
some peace sacrifice going like those
things do work occasionally but i don't
know if they work here exactly it feels
wrong
um jump right in uh christian uh other
games that caught your eye
by the way you guys were spot on with
your analysis after bishop to f6 which
probably is the best movie in the
position not e3 because of knight to b3
but bishop to g5 and this actually gives
white quite a serious advantage in the
position nepo is definitely aware of
this version
uh actually played a five which you
played that fire
that's almost losing
almost
losing plus one point seven right now
from zero zero zero yeah but one point
seven i don't think c5 no it takes two
you actually take and what do you think
what he takes i assume is the point he
takes and now i go b3
this is the key move if you take then i
just simply go queen to c through i'm
going to recapture that and then i'm
going to make use of the much better
structure not only that but also the two
bishops i'm going to go bishop to f4 c7
is weak d5 with f5 is a weakness as well
this just seems to be a dominant
position i do want to say that
you know the one the 1.7 currently is
not the the yeah and the it's not human
one point and uh jan has already played
bishop before which i assume maybe is
not as harsh as as knight takes d5 even
though white still remains
sort of in control but maintains a
significant edge oh i want to say
for for me one of these players who
really uh played for the structure i i
like the structure uh knight takes d5
wouldn't have been my instant
desire
but bishop f4 i very very much like it
it was just followed by quincy one right
and then we you know
yeah and i
start weaving some pressure against the
c7 pawn don't know how i'm going to
attack the c4 pawn but bishop d6 came
rather quickly as a response
um by hikaru i must say i'm assuming
quincy one yeah
but i there might be other options as
well but that would be my immediate
but then at some moment i do start
thinking like i should be playing knight
takes d5 and i should be playing for
knight e5 peter having having said that
let's say we go bishop takes a four here
with the queen that was the six yeah
that was the idea it still remains kind
of ugly but
it's
really not that horrible because it's
difficult to attack what
are supposed to be the weaknesses here i
i don't see anything immediately so
you're saying that you want this
position
wand is a strong word
i'm saying i might hold it
this is i don't know either that might
not be the most joyful no experience
joyful
yeah not on the list of things i was
going to claim right
right
okay uh an intriguing position for sure
i wanted to go uh to our farugi game if
you didn't mind uh it was like the
veteran versus the youth this was the
exciting uh khara khan and
i make a mistake in these positions by
always trying to compare them with
french defenses and they're really not
they're a completely
different animal
and it's oftentimes that you're not even
playing
for the move a c5 yeah i think you're
playing for the f6 break very exactly
and this whole concept of knight e1 and
f4 i think one and as we as we see it's
more connected with the idea of playing
bishop d3 and uh
but now i'm not entirely sure what
uh linear is supposed to do yeah because
once the king actually gets to g8 even
c65 will definitely reappear on the
agenda but the 7 f6 is as you're
correctly pointing out is probably the
the most important break that
black tries to achieve is there an issue
here with the bishop on h7 can i try to
embarrass you or
shamefully uh play queen c2 with the
idea of g4 just to embarrass
this bishop or if i if i really have to
worry about this i can play bishop g6 i
assume right um but i'm also kind of
wondering if if i can maybe play c6 c5
but bishop six i think is a standby so
you you mean something like this where
nothing's gone wrong
um yeah i'm not sure nothing has gone
wrong but
i haven't lost the piece which i think
was my first
which is a good thing the immediate
concern was to to not be pissed down by
multiple
you're lowering the bar with each ear
right
peter is that what's going on over here
okay uh interesting are we in
theoretical territory as far as lanier
and uh ali reza there's still some games
not yet no no no not anymore not not
anymore and actually that there's been a
game between sergey kareckin and alireza
himself uh bishop d3 appears to be a
novelty comparison knight to d3 was the
move played
knight d3 bishop two three seven rook to
e1 and a completely different approach
from uh ali reza from karjakin excuse me
but now it does seem like dominguez came
with this bishop to d3 idea and knight
to d2 now watch this yeah i'm not sure i
like this
yeah where are you going with that
knight c5 what about c5 yeah exactly
like why are we allowing black so much
freedom to start breaking wow
it doesn't make too much sense to my
eyes
i understand you're trying to reroute
this knight is not greatly placed maybe
you want to go b3 later on but
putting the knight on f3 what are you
going to do with this knight on e1 are
you going to get it to e3 perhaps how
are you going to get there knight to c
knight to e3 or g3 knight to g2 i think
his intention has got to be associated
with g4 um
you know like you want to play g4 right
now or c5 uh no i didn't think so i
think i wanted to play knight f3 first i
want you to take on d4 yeah but i think
we can take this is the issue that uh i
don't think we're fast enough i think
yeah
go ahead try it on your board uh
c5 knight f3 knight or three take on d4
g5 and now g4 yes yes knight to h4 i
take on h7
i'm assuming you take another three take
one three
and i make some i think you have to take
with the pawn right because otherwise
you lose uh the pawn on true five you
take with the knight so taking with the
pawn about
maybe knight to ba knight to c6 and
maybe i can even consider a long castle
later on or just
yeah just leave the king in the center i
think yeah most likely the king stays in
the center here but yeah once the knight
lands on c6 castling long becomes much
less of a looks decent for players yeah
i think i remember these uh slav
defenses that sometimes you go
knight to c6 to b8 a cool game very very
interesting but guys i want to ask you
about this game please in particular
peter because you're such an expert in
the groove felt now explain to me is
this something that mvl perhaps had in
store from home or is this just he's
playing very quickly and he is that's
yeah and uh yeah some of the decisions
he made were it did not seem obvious
queen takes b2 this is the big deal yeah
first of all queen takes b2 there and
secondly like he blitzed out bb-8 which
didn't really seem like it was such a
clearly
clearly you know the best
option in
uh in the game
i don't know it's possible he's looked
at this it's as i mentioned uh
the whole idea of playing queen c2 there
is arguably maybe the most topical
like bishop bishop v5 check on move
eight has become very very fashionable
some time ago and in the bishop b5
checklines this is maybe the most uh the
most uh immediately popular
uh so it's it's it's not impossible that
mbl actually has a very concrete idea
about how to treat it
i've been looking at the current
position trying to figure out what i
think i'm i'm very confused
my
like generally i always feel that the
pieces have enough for the queen and it
should be uh it should be okay for black
but
i don't know it's uh it's a bit
mystifying the the the
the big question i have for
everyone here is why can't we take on a7
what's the what's the reason we can't if
i correct way queen c7
and how do we feel about yeah i want to
continue kind of for
being annoying and uh attacking just one
or both of your rooks yeah right dc8
queen b7 and so on like i
once again it doesn't feel like this is
a huge problem it feels like it should
be manageable it feels like it should be
holdable for black but
i'm not sure exactly what the solution
is and um
i'm struggling
it seems like after queen takes a7
bishop to h6 is the move
bishop to h6
on f4 right okay
but still white is still better that's
the thing that's why i'm a bit surprised
about his decision to go
sacrifice this queen just like that it
doesn't feel like he's equalizing as
easily as he uh thought he would and
there's so many reasons why you could be
completely losing if you allow this pawn
to go down the board a few more moves
you're going to be completely losing
you're going to be in trouble if the
a-pawn starts running yeah i understand
white's white setup is a bit awkward and
bish basics is a very very clever move
starting it really is i mean it just you
want once you start to look at i mean
after all there is this long-term pin
you still have to uh yeah but you want a
pawn and you're ready to go a4 a5 but
bishop h6 is nasty as g3 h4 plays itself
and
f5 well
that would take twice we're quite okay
with with the idea the two bishops
uh
really uh
difficult in violence to uh play
players who like
the queens
will be happy players who like the minor
pieces as you say rook and bishop and if
you got a pawn a lot of green felt
players are happy with those
sacrifices
wow
beside queen a7 i thought his intention
of f4 actually was just to play
knight back but then you you but then
you're thinking that's an easy that's
just the draw right yeah
take it take on d1 take one
yeah and uh even if we end up losing
both e7 and a7 pawns we probably still
don't lose that position he has played
it on on cue yeah
does play does play knight five and yeah
and uh yeah for our audience uh what
what peter and i are just
saying is that in any situation like
this okay but he played 95 isn't he's
just a draw on the spot this is that's
what we're talking about this is what
we're exactly yeah i think it's just a
draw yeah i think let's say we go queen
to seven here and yeah my argument is
we lose
this guy
queen a7 bishop
takes c7 and we go and again yeah we're
just sitting there saying
oh or we appreciate it or whatever we're
so pleased
can you somehow try to get the king too
i go king age seven yeah i go king h7
and i stay on age seven and i don't
think it goes any further yeah i'm
pretty sure this is a draw uh it might
not be the most fun draw to make in the
world but i'm pretty sure i think it's
pretty uh pretty easy actually something
uh let's jump around uh we haven't
checked in on fabi for some time
by the way uh fabian lavon have really
been moving right along he didn't go for
the knight f6 by the way he put his
knight on e5 now that also makes sense
but um
he was sort of provoked by bishop d3 the
bishop appeared on d3 before black
committed to any square for the knights
so it gave a temper to 95. and the
current position is kind of weird
because
um
i'm happy with white i'm happy with this
pawn on e5 yeah i guess i guess you
prefer white here it shouldn't be much
but you definitely prefer white like
bishop three followed by e6
i was looking at bishop d5 right now but
if you play bishop d5 i probably go
bishop c2 and i start hinting at some
kind of queen d3 shenanigans but maybe
honestly like kha bishop d3 quick bishop
g8
it looks passive but i've solved all of
my tactical issues there will not be a
threat in this game anymore right this
should just be fine for black to be
honest okay i think this should just be
fine for black uh the uh very creative
king h8 and bishop g8 should be noted
um but christian jumped fast it's funny
because you can uh threaten checkmate on
h7 and i can threaten checkmate on a2
and probably white has to go be sure
there should be one yeah we get we get
this really weird symmetrical
symmetrical uh echoes let's just put
that on the board for everybody to see
rookie won and i want to blockade the
pawn oops no no no no like some sort of
a stalemate yeah
[Laughter]
it's not it's amusing but yeah should be
i think should be fine for both i feel
like this is probably quite quite level
i don't like what jan has done to his
position i want to say i i think
uh
once uh hikaru made a move which wasn't
the best i think
you know we left it at bishop f4 yeah uh
hikaru played bishop b6 and jan went 95
straight away i thought i sort of assume
i assumed black will take but hicario
just went queen e8
e4
and then a lot of material got off the
board with hp5595
this honestly feels like
not very much at all uh to my eyes but
maybe because of this grip on the king
side uh and you know potential for some
attacks on the king said maybe white
still has something but really it looks
to me like
by far you know the worst is behind uh
hikaru here at this point yeah there's
plenty of counter play against the beats
pawn the king on h2 is really not that
safe having you know since we had to
play four
this doesn't really look horrible at all
for black well shankland versus
mamadiarov is definitely going to be a
draw anytime soon it feels like the game
which has the most content still remains
that one between dominious and firuja so
many pieces still on the board so many
details
in the position i really uh would like
to keep an eye on that one by the way g7
g5
uh was
kind of played rather quickly against
this move knight d2 yeah saying yeah
please play knight f3 so they can chase
it further away exactly
everywhere and h2h3 was kind of the
prelude to
well
he decided against c5 which is a little
bit surprising to my eyes we can do it
again you can do it again now and
perhaps not even worry about g4 as much
as he would have had to worry about g4
earlier although actually it's still
playable right it's not much has changed
true so let's go c5 c5 knight df3 i'm
assuming this is still the plan gcd g4
can i get extremely aggressive and try
to go h5 here well bishop takes g number
bishop thank you sorry yeah we should
play g4 g5 is going to be a problem yeah
i think that is uh and if i try to go to
ga then that never well careful because
once again g2 g4 this bishop
could uh
could land with a
i'm trying to sacrifice material and i'm
also thinking about completely
discombubulated line
something like bishop
yeah
sometimes sometimes things like this are
actually quite playable there's a bunch
of lines in particular in like the
advanced fringe these days where white
just gives up the pawn on d4 and
continues playing like no problem okay
i'm a central pawn down
and
there was a very very fast draw hardly
got into the game between
sam and uh shaq
that came out of a very we actually did
not cover any of this but it was a very
quiet game and as i mentioned it was uh
you know by far the
by far the quietest of the round
by the way nothing really uh happened
why did jeffrey take on the e-7 because
the a-pawn isn't running i understand
that but
isn't this the only way in which you
could potentially buy a miracle lose
this i don't think so if i get the
route wait a minute i agree with you
completely chris wait a minute why not
take on a7 right like get rid of the one
pawn because he wants to play for a win
if he takes on a7 he never wins the e7
black gloves king of f8 and this one you
really like now who's playing for a win
my question is
i thought well maybe i can in this case
because remember what peter said you
could put your king on h7 in your rook
on g8 and draw in your sleeve
but maybe uh you cannot get you whenever
you get the king to f6 i give you a
check on f1
i'm not going to a f6 i'm going to h6 i
keep the king on h7 okay so let's go a4
first okay a4 you go king g5 i go king
hso
and i go queen here
okay
ah you give me a check okay check
sorry a3
king g8
yeah this is probably a way to lose
right
and a2 yeah we have actually lost the
game
we successfully managed to lose this
yeah give me some chances
i mean we went all the way don't you
feel terrible
and he's done it he's gone rook a2
and this is
well it's funny that i mean at some
point you have to pull the brakes but
right i guess you open up the h file
with g4 and then just give her perpetual
yeah yeah this is probably a very nice
bailout you just play g4 allowing ghgh
is not very attractive but once yeah
once we have a check from h4 we're never
losing i mean the queen is a the queen
is a queen with like white
normally has a lot of leeway in
positions like this but i can feel uh i
can almost sense the cheering that's
going on for the grunfeld uh
crowd specialists who are saying look at
it what's such an easy easy easy draw
but what you wanted to say uh
though
was that after bishop e6 if you don't
take on e7
king f8
and that is very very confusing that's
just completely safe nothing nothing to
discuss whatsoever so we are expecting a
draw in that game we know the farouza
game is exciting we know the hikaru game
is exciting and lavon
i think hikaru is not completely fine
because uh i wanted to just a second
you're saying who's completely fine
shigaru
this is yeah this is this is probably
also very very close to complete the
quality i don't see how anyone wins this
i mean if you can try to push bishop
take c5 and e6
i mean
let's say let's bring oh
sorry i'm on the wrong game
is it the push i mean it like it's very
double h right because it is yeah the d4
d3 will also start happening it is no i
i'm not saying hikaru is worse
so take take an e6
[Music]
i don't know it's better than why
right
the fabled question of
you gotta have nerves of steel to play
these types of four maybe
queenie for queen g6
e4 i want to e4 because rugby took in h3
i'm slightly hopeless hopeful because e7
will be a threat but we can play g4 g3
for now
we don't have to commit right i was
thinking yeah yeah that was also also a
plan yeah for sure so
just d3 here right d3 what if i go
invite
i was thinking about b4 actually but
i don't think it works before you just
take it on b i think we take it before i
think vintage before it's playable it's
fine okay
uh yeah no that's an invitation to yeah
jan decides not to do it because
and hikaru solidifies everything with
seven c66 yeah
blick is just fine because yes white has
a slightly safer key i mean if anyone is
better as black honestly like rugby
three queen e3
like i can i can i can actually name
okay just a second 23.
are we absolutely absolutely certain
about this stuff
i
think you're trying to lose
i guess we i think you're trying to lose
you might not succeed because
you have uh i have prepared yeah you
have enough
perpetual fallbacks but i i think you're
trying to lose there yes yeah okay so we
go tanks takes h5 just to make sure that
i do have
i have a perpetuating case for a p2 but
what am i trying to do i'm trying to i
have no idea what your threat is to be
honest
yeah
yeah no okay okay
c7 c6 looks like a fantastic move i
agree if we can get in moves like rook
b3 and queen e3
i started to feel like black is
maybe yeah i start to look for a [ __ ]
this is what i'm arguing yeah that you
have to be careful here with white you
have to actually find a way to make
you know if you see an immediate draw
here you should take it for sure
absolutely yeah like if you find a way
to make an immediate draw just make it
straight away because yeah you're you're
probably not going to enjoy
uh
so can we do that somehow let's say
simplify the position
let's try with f5 yeah exactly i was
wondering if f5 actually makes the draw
yeah this was awesome also my question
here if f5 just makes a draw on the spot
which which it might i'm scared of queen
e3 actually
it was six queenie three
i it was this
yeah and this is where i go this is
where i go queen g6 and actually make a
drop ah
this is my point and then if seven f5 f8
i have five yeah no i i apologize i was
thinking that d2 was uh
yeah well i mean i i
if i don't have the perpetual i resign
there but i do have a perpetual that's
the difference
just to show everybody uh what i had
forgotten was that there's no perpetual
on h5 but there is a perpetual
on f5 on f5 yeah i i get saved sort of
slightly miraculously there but i do get
saved
instead goes rookie two
which is yeah he continues to play you
know somewhat passively rook t2 as c6
right yeah e2
okay well we're stopping queen e3 yeah
24 played queen d4 24 played we can now
start chasing this rook like we can go
rookie 2.3 rookie 2 and perhaps start
doing that
i don't think queen b3 is something that
we need to be much worried about between
d3
let's go to the jeffrey game because
this is going to be most likely
yeah i mean jeffrey understands that
he's not really playing for a win here
so yeah that that one
is about to finish exactly as we were
expecting him to to realize it's time to
to find an immediate draw and he did
play g4 and
yeah i don't know what nba was thinking
about because there's always going to be
checks yeah yeah i think he's just
saying i'm going to play this move and
we're going to agree to a draw uh again
a big shout out to grunfeld aficionado
who's saying
our favorite defense holds and back to
farouja and the fun
that's going on in that game
i'm not sure i like what he's done to
his position he volunteered after the
move h2h3 didn't wait for
to be provoked with the move g2 g4
there's reasons why you want to be
provoked but he played knight h4 i think
he wants to stop knight of three like
after knight of three g4 would have
become
an issue because h4 the h4 square
wouldn't have been such a comfortable uh
hideout for the knight i mean now now we
go g3 we go like knight d3 knight f3 and
we have a i think a pleasant position
for white right where am i putting this
guy by the way tell me i'm not sure okay
i'll get i'll stay
i'll i'll i'll stay on yeah
df3 pro tonight pardon me knight d2
three of three do you want to start with
knight f3
cc also possibly i wasn't sure if i won
those knights off the board but yeah
that's also an option just not play g3
at all just go knight f3 here okay
and
i'm assuming i i
want to play for c5
yeah but that doesn't really give you
that much like we need b3
queen e2 defends the pawn on b2 perhaps
bishop e3 and then i will sidestep and
start pushing for f4 right i will like
go knight h2 and start preparing you
have to be careful about if you do go
long castle i have ideas of c4
absolutely yeah that's my favorite thing
to do in these types of structures
and uh jan seems to have found a way i
guess he feels that this is enough to
make an immediate draw
because he after 24 he took on d5 which
is an extremely ugly move to make but
if you're connected with the idea of
playing queen g6 next move and you are
sure that you have perpetuals everywhere
it's probably the way to go queen b6 f5
doesn't look like a way to play for a
win
so you take on bitsu and then we'll take
quintex66 as a perpetual for sure
exactly you might be playing for being
worse after queen b6 yeah the m605 you
might actually struggle to to equalize
yeah and has he played rook b2 it looks
like they've kind of yes he has yeah
rugby to queen elizabeth's on the board
yeah
yes and you can't really avoid the
perpetual and i don't think he will be
trying to wear the perpetual too much
okay
uh yeah this game the catalan this game
is done yeah the catalan fails to win
for jan which is a kind of a breaking
news type situation but
he did get uh
he got a very nice position
he was pushing this whole queen a1
concept
why is jan thinking right now
is he trying to probably because he's
got 20 minutes on his clock right
but about how do you try yeah
and then go king age threes yeah that
doesn't seem like much of a winning
attempt yeah well come on we've got
nothing else to do just a second
take take take uh
yeah i want to i want to say i also have
a perpetual here if i need to okay
and i was supposed to be able to move my
queen away with a gain of tempo so i had
i could play e6 and your checks would
drive my king
no by the way we've got another uh
result it would appear between fabi and
levon and i suspect they've agreed yeah
it's a
it's a three-fold they play queen d4
king h7 queen d3 king h8 and so on yeah
which leaves us with our remaining game
uh which has actually
been the most intriguing game of the
round thus far and by the way knight f3
no nitrate but knight g6
but now you don't have to play the move
g3 absolutely yeah i think yeah
you can just win a tempo you got
absolutely not g3 b3
you got the position that you wanted
with
out
will run into b4 problems
like bhp3 followed by b2b4 will be a
very very natural reaction to black
castling coincide
i feel like black has to go c5 right
yeah it looks like it's uh yeah this is
kind of annoying that uh the desirable
h5g
h5 g4
i'm it's
it's not that
easy for me to i'm going to have to play
rook g8 queen d8 it's very slow and
you're getting in the moment
in the meantime something will start
happening on the other side of the board
which will be a huge destruction exactly
again just uh for our audience what
we're kind of looking at is before
yeah i want to go h5 g4 get my attacking
but it just feels like white gets there
first yeah it seems like yeah something
something will start happening here d5
is interesting even b takes a 5 is not
stupid and that is the draw that we
expected but b5
i might be able to hide behind that uh
protective b-pawn and you can see that
dionne is not very happy yeah he knows
he knows he could have uh could have
posed more christmas more yeah for sure
uh again the
are you happy here or what do you think
uh peter i mean
i'm never happy but uh i'm never happy
but uh
[Music]
i think my position is b6 b6 or c4 like
all of those things are you know very
much on the menu here
okay very cool is time a factor in this
in this three against nine so
finally is you know staying true to form
because
if nothing else he should generally be a
much faster player than
uh than linear is because lanier
generally plays
slower yeah
very very
you know
knight c2 interestingly he
chooses a different uh route for uh for
that knight he's aiming for maybe the
immediate b2b4 plans and the knight
might go to e3 to perhaps stop
those h4 h5 g4 types of play ideas but
maybe also whenever black is going to
build c5 he's aiming for the b5 square
with knight
a6 almost immediately well taking away
some squares like white perhaps would
like to place the queen on that diagonal
so this is all now taken away no queen
d3 ideas in other words
hmm
i'm still curious about playing before
actually i kind of want to immediately
start asking some questions on that
flank
okay they you do give up the c4 square
yeah
they know 96 first yeah 96's yeah this
is actually another reason for queen a6
okay uh
we're gonna have uh fabi uh joining
christian
uh as we get him miked up uh
what do you say let's put the guy to
work i mean that way we can take a break
and fabby can you absolutely i'm
anything
anything that reduces our workload
put it on his shoulders fair enough uh
queen a6 uh cool move and knight fe1
played by linear linear is playing this
very very kind of slowly and knight fe1
all of these high falutin
high class maneuvering yeah i have no
idea what this is yeah why are we why
are we inviting h5
is f4s intent knight d3 f4
well we don't actually have an idea of
what's happening in this position right
but maybe we can ask fabiano that's what
i'm saying about this position fabiano
let's exploit the guy help us out i'm
not sure i have an idea either but i
wouldn't take white here that's for sure
you would take white oh yeah it looks
like a good position um
why
yeah i mean so let's go h5 sure how
would you hold your attack which i would
like b4 or f4 i wouldn't be worried
about knight d3 g4 but low on time maybe
he wants to play queen d3 queen d3 here
i mean
two queens yeah yeah at least at least
you don't get under attack but it's also
an ambitious move yeah i guess knight d3
g4 is the is the question but how does
white respond to that and by the way h5
was played on the board right now well
alireza will take advantage of lanier's
lack of time for sure g
g3 oh that's a good move that looks nice
yeah what if you go g4 and h4 h4n
then black has to do something right
i would think that the normal move is e
takes of six here
yeah in this position which is very
complicated i i
yeah lanier
shouldn't have let his time get so low
although he plays very well
with limited time
it's a complicated position and he'll be
playing a complex middle game with
basically on
relying on increment for the rest of the
game
uh but yeah it'll be exciting speaking
of alireza you actually scored an
important victory uh against him take us
through that game and what were the
critical moments
did he just lose the game with one move
in the opening
yeah i mean the critical moment was on
on move three
i played a great move here i played
knight f6 okay
after that i don't know what one can do
berlin of course yeah
and yeah something went wrong for him i
i mean he he was
he was on his own
and you actually played this position
with the white pieces yeah yeah
yeah i took on c6 and then d4
so i knew something about it i was
trying to remember what happens i mean
e4 e5 queen g7
cd bishop v6 a4 was the game a4 a5 and
knight c4
and this is all i remembered and how
black is supposed to play this i
couldn't remember but
um but d4 came as a shock immediately
because i didn't understand i mean
i didn't understand why i can't play ed4
also but then i thought
why not eliminate the bishop immediately
i mean you yeah i was thinking d takes
e5 is probably the
like the best move but
you've accepted like a very bad position
from the opening
so like psychologically it's really
tough to play this you want you want to
at least sack upon and try to make
create some mess on the board which is
what he should try to do here and then
you guys got to this position it did
feel like after rook to b5 this was an
invitation to you i thought maybe
it because rook b3 i wasn't
i suddenly realized that rook b3 queen
g7 and queen b1 is a little bit annoying
a because a5 is a threat knight c4
bishop a6
knight b6 i was trying to figure this
out bishop f1 knight
d7 or
or d5 i don't know then i take and
you have queen a1 yeah i also have rook
d8 which is easy but queen n1 is nice as
well then bishop to c4 you can you don't
have time to take whenever yeah this is
sort of the stuff i was looking at and
then he shocked me from b5
i mean this is uh
yeah he was just going all in this was
desperation
faviano slow start in day one minus one
in that one plus one in day two now
you're back to uh 50 how do you feel
about your chances no overall it was a
good day i think i i could have maybe
done two and a half today because i i
don't know if i ever had winning chances
against lanier but it was definitely
definitely seemed like he was in danger
and i also thought i got to slide
something against levon in the last game
not much but uh
but a little something okay i don't
think i had any like serious winning
chances but definitely some chances to
push in the remaining games still a good
result today congratulations we'll see
you tomorrow fabian thank you
what
uh we we've seen a few moves since uh
you've been discussing your
this entire line appeared on the board
and uh 94 did you still like the
assessment uh
of uh white's you you feel white still
slightly better
or the bishops came off the bishops came
off
for white right and like in a vacuum
you'd think that
black's bishop was better than whites
yeah that being said i
oh
just fade in rook f3 is coming yeah he
just castles queenside and also linear
is nearing that point where he will be
playing on increment he's down to 45
seconds against
more than eight minutes foreign this is
not a fun position to play i'm wondering
will you like play knight c5 just an
attempt to get rid of the knight yeah
take stakes e5 i was also looking at
that yeah and just start pushing
yeah what are you pushing exactly like
before queen c4 and then i don't know e4
might be five knight f3 i don't know
uh looks very dodgy he goes with key one
maybe he wants vertex e4 now mm-hmm at
least as
kind of a backup backup plan yeah so how
do you stop rook takes c4 i don't think
well do you want to well yeah exactly i
don't think we need so we can play rook
of fate or rook f7 or maybe even the
funny thing is that like let's say rook
f8 take on e4 take knight c5 you can't
play queen c4 because your queen gets
trapped yeah
yeah this is why maybe rook f7 was
better all right so you have to go to b6
i guess
well let's let's go rook f7 this is this
is my point i think if we go rook f7
instead of rook fade
you have the same line i will have to
take c5 there in the middle why is that
good for black
knight v5 93 i don't know oh okay 90
yeah 95.
i think i was what was my point
sorry knight e3 and as opposed to the
previous position now i have queen take
c5 i take on d1
uh i go knight t5 and i land it either
on d3 or on f3
yeah knight e5 and rook d6 oh
i missed i will i will
knight d3 but still i think blick or
just fine yeah six as well yeah
yeah this
also work f6 was uh asking the question
of what what the rook is doing on d6
yeah obviously none of this is forced
but
it's like both of you have calculated
the line very very quickly
but then you at the end of the
calculation you have to make the
judgment yeah that's the five that's
that's the trick that's the tricky part
right yeah and he goes he goes for it he
goes 65 which was another option that we
were it's very logical to be briefly
briefly mentioning after rookie one did
he put just play the 65 here right
which was more i don't know can white
uh
yeah this is starting to get dangerous
for white
yeah and also 15 seconds yeah like
that's not yeah let's not forget about
the 15 seconds bit yeah d now we can
just i think take twice is fine we can
also maybe make a waiting move of some
sort but just taking twice feels very
logical yeah sounds like queen b6
exactly as yesterday yeah i think when
your opponent has 15 seconds just
play the simple moves and let him
think on that then find the ghosts
honestly it just looks like black is
sort of taking over because rook f8 is
coming the knight on e4 is
i think perfect eternal yeah it's never
going to get chased away and there's
never going to be any time for white to
launch anything on the queen side the
king's side structure is definitely
favorable do you play
knight
d4 i think we have to yeah but and rook
cafe and how how do you rookie too i
mean it's ugly what else can i do but
queen z2 rookie one i mean you'll you'll
start to consolidate a bit
even if i get all of that
c5 knight b5 queen f6 maybe
well yeah but it's double-edged it's
double-edged yeah
and queen c2 does cover things and it's
interesting that he's been he he's still
thinking about dtak c5 because uh
clearly he doesn't want to give a linear
uh a chance to make a couple of obvious
moves yeah he keeps keeps attention
yeah
wait what about
rookie four
and knight c5 knight c5 and queen
yeah
knight g5 quincy four queen d6
it doesn't really create a threat
yeah
three two two
okay yeah he played knight he's one
second he played it with one second one
second
yeah oh my goodness i'm playing it with
zero seconds
thrill seeker
yeah our linear dominguez is right so
queen f7 looks very good yeah quintiful
he'll have to play queen to six nothing
else makes any sense i mean queen d4
exists but then knight takes e5 no when
you fall on x5 resign so you have to
play windy six and yeah queen f7 looks
very very tasty queen before
oh he's kind of looking around yeah yeah
yeah i'd ask you uh does that affect you
and no you're a shack you always end up
playing window six yeah but queen of
seven queenie
looks very good right yeah queen of
seven looks very very strong yeah
queenie two is an attempt to win on the
spot yeah right
rook f1 but after looking for one i
don't see in the media i thought after
phone i would find something but i don't
see it yet now if one queen situation
kind of game continues
so queen f7 the queen of 70 and 94.95 it
looks like things will start collapsing
very soon 95 and
do you have knight d4
um oh yeah 94 perhaps keeps the game off
knight c4 though yeah hold on which line
are we looking for f7 we take only four
four knight takes e5 not takes e5 yeah
this looks hopeless
yeah so the end game after queen takes
c5 i would assume is just lost yeah
maybe you have to do that but it's i
mean not to lose on this but yeah you'll
lose eventually
queen d6 is on the board and it looks i
think his other moves are so tempting
that maybe that's uh
that's a little bit annoying for alireza
that he has so many good options right
the simple one is a little bit
well maybe queen f7 rook f1 is the best
chance
knight 65 and now
uh
at least our knight isn't hanging
he has played queen f7 yeah queen of
seven yeah he finally settles on on the
right way i think i'm pretty sure not
even bothering with queen e2 is just by
father he's got the best technical
solution he's going to go rook fun and
reza will take on e5 with the knight
i just don't see any real 95 93 i i
don't know what i can do yeah i think
you're kind of gone yeah there's no
attack rook d8 drives away the rook from
with the queen from d6 if we need to
it's just bad
i mean i don't need to win the game
immediately
yeah you have to go queen agency queen
h6
mind d3
93
also looks like a very very cultured
decision there just offering a queen
trade shirt
yeah
yeah
queen
he lost that last time
yeah but the position is also probably
completely lost so it's not really
wow uh that collapsed
that just collapsed very quickly
from a tense middle game because of the
time situation but mainly mainly because
you you you can't live
you can't
we get to see the flag two one no not
there not there
there
double clutch gets them every time
uh i'm forcefully uh reminded uh of your
game with jeffrey zhang from the america
cup round one fabiano uh where it is
kind of a
a nonchalant move by jeffrey at the very
end and he flagged here i think it's a
bit less painful for linear because his
position was lost while jeffrey was
completely winning
good point
slightly
well uh thank you so much for joining us
uh bobby and nice uh to see you recover
from your minus score from day one uh
look forward to tomorrow thanks
absolutely
and that is a remarkable uh one win per
round but each round
that is yeah
fulfilling games i want to say yeah very
very interesting chess plenty of plenty
for us to talk about in in every round
today but so far
today we've had a very steady diet of
one one decisive game per day which is
very unusual i think right or for the
gct rapid and blitz events we were
having two yeah per round i think in day
one yeah and i think in uh in poland we
had generally we had even more than two
per day right on most days so yeah it's
a it's a bit quiet in terms of uh actual
results but we we have no complaints
about the either the content whatsoever
absolutely
and uh we'll have uh ali reza
joining us shortly but uh christian your
thoughts of day two i mean i have to say
i'm mightily impressed with the way
alireza is carrying himself in this
tournament he lost against fabiano but
did not collapse after that immediately
came back with a bounce back victory
with the black pieces against such a
solid player like lanier his time
situation his time management is
definitely uh very very good right now
ali reza's that is and i really like
what i'm seeing from him also from
fabiano a very difficult day one we know
that fabiano had a bad candidates bad
olympia and started pretty poorly in day
one in the saint louis rabbit and blitz
but then bounce back huge victory with
the black pieces against alireza that
one was a good one definitely looking
forward to see what's going to happen
tomorrow is going to be a fiery finish i
have to say
thank you christian again i'd like to
draw your attention to what i want to
say is a kind of collapse e65 fine and
we've got this position and
at first we had fabiano in studio saying
that he kind of preferred white why did
why did
white's position collapse so
honestly you know it it feels like you
know we we invited him here and we kind
of kept him here yeah
clever yeah when christian was ready to
to let him go but i i will still go on
the record saying that i i was a bit
mystified by his assessment of these
positions because it looked to me that
the knight on e4 is just such a dominant
piece uh that i i couldn't quite figure
out why he liked it so much for white
and
no
i don't think the events necessarily
born
bore this out because i think the the
very very quick collapse was
a lot to do with the time management and
okay less to do with the position but
still yeah
even optically this looks better for
black for me exactly well he was
mentioning something like let's
let's just put the position that he had
in mind right we had some position like
this in mind
where he was going to go queen c2 and
it's not that bad but he's still big
black here i think yeah just because of
the knight on the e4 but the whole
exchange sacrifice idea that lanier came
up with was actually three seconds and
he had to make a move basically right
and it worked out wonderfully for
farouja who happens to be with christian
alireza you won your game but you came
into the studio and you were shaking
your head you seem a bit disappointed
did you feel like you could get more out
of today's rounds yeah i'm very
disappointed with fabiano's game
i just
still am very upset about that game so
because i lost just against myself
because he didn't do
anything special of course it was not
needed so
what happened in the opening you played
that move at d4 after quite a serious
thing eight minutes yeah i had to take
on c6 first and then go d4 so that was
the theory but i just completely
messed up the
move order so yeah and that was after
that i didn't have any chance
yeah absolutely and then you immediately
bounced back big victory with the black
pieces what was the strategy going into
the last round did you want to keep the
tension in the position and play a long
game was that the strategy yeah i played
quaragon um
normally it's a kind of a risky line
nowadays
and white gets a very interesting game
but i thought it's at least something to
try i i was not in the mood to defend
just play for draw i wanted to have
chances also to play for win so
i thought i felt that that's a good
um that's a good
strategy but also i was lucky that he
was not in a good shape indeed for this
game he's throughout the game throughout
the tournament he's in a good shape but
here it did feel like he was putting
some pressure early on
but he was also burning through a lot of
his time yes he was thinking a lot my g5
is so unnecessary
i am move 13
13 g5 yes yeah g5 is just
um it's unnecessary i wanted to but you
played it fast yeah i played it very
quickly so but it's not a good choice i
think because i create a lot of
um weaknesses and h3 is a great move
now he just wants knight f3 yeah i think
c5 is only moved to go and keep going
i i didn't know what to do after knight
df3
cd4 g4
this is actually what like yasser was
recommending as well like g3
thanks yeah it was thinking uh this
takes takes rook f2
bishop c5
queen e2 and decent game i'm okay wow
yeah somehow c takes b2 and then take on
f2 and yeah just because i felt that
this game maybe it's close to draw so i
wanted to keep the game going because he
didn't have enough time so yeah here i
knew that i may be okay but
um
i still think that maybe my choice is
better practically absolutely you did
kept a lot of pieces and a lot of
tension still in the position and then
it felt like he went for this very
strange not knight f e1 right were you
surprised by his decision yeah
it's a strange move but he has very
little time on the clock he has two
three minutes so
it just feels like he's giving you
enough time to go h5 yes normally if you
don't have time with white you always
think about going f4 so
he wanted to go immediately knight d3 f4
so but he didn't have time to think
about h5 93 g4 i think this is what he
missed
and he and now it gets very messy so he
has to go b4 it's a complete mass
position
and he went for g3
yeah and then i think i'm okay here
and here it's very difficult for him to
play
practically because my knight is very
strong and he cannot challenge it so
yeah this is exactly what peter was
mentioning as well after e5 just from a
practical perspective especially with 15
seconds on the clock yeah it's not like
you're almost winning yeah it's almost
impossible to defend this over the board
with 10 seconds so
um yeah
yeah i was kind of
lucky that he had a little time to sink
in the middle game so alireza is still
the leader after uh two days going into
the final rapid uh day how do you feel
about your performance so far yeah after
the last round um i'm pretty happy but
the previous game i still should work on
it to forget about it so
um
yeah it's a it's an interesting
tournament a lot of ups and downs a lot
of people winning losing um we will see
what is going to happen the next few
days finally you're sporting this nba
shirt which one is your uh favorite
thing
um
i always said chicago is very good
yeah
but there are many good teams now
thank you ali reza we'll see you
tomorrow thank you
thank you indeed uh ali reza and let's
take a look at the
standings after two eventful days of
rapid peter and there we have we we are
back to the situation with that reza at
the top there and three people chasing
him but slightly different three people
with linear dropping back into the fifty
percent zone exactly
maximum and jeffrey shong are on seven
out of twelve alireza there at the top
on eight uh then a bunch of people on
fifty percent uh levon and hicaron minus
one and shakhria are on minus three i
believe that is
uh
still a full day of rapid awaits us
tomorrow three more rounds of rapid and
then 18 rounds of bleeds on monday and
tuesday that will be
tremendously exciting to uh to to call
yeah absolutely christian final thoughts
of today's action as we prepare to say
good night well it was just another
amazing day of chess uh my pick still is
doing quite well ali reza in top
position so i cannot complain about that
young nepo plus one but definitely
showcasing some very interesting ideas
especially with the white pieces in that
catalan is going to be a very very
exciting day three and we're going to be
here to call all the action absolutely
thank you thank you everyone uh for
sharing your day
your weekend with us uh be sure to join
us tomorrow for our third and final
rounds thank you and good night see you
then
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you